foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
land of fjords Majestic mountains Cliffs
and waterfalls
in addition to stunning geography Norway
is home to the greatest chess player who
has ever lived Magnus Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best from Carlson's fiercest online
rival today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps laude Beck
abdusotourov and kukesh domaraju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023. Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana
two more long-time Headliners seek to
take their next turn Atop A major
tournament Wesley so and Shakira Mamet
yarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field
who will come out on top will Carlson
run the table yet again or will someone
else usurp the throne this
is Norway chess
hello and welcome to beautiful Stavanger
and as we cross the halfway point of
Norway chess the excitement is reaching
its peak Fabiana caruana is sailing away
from the competition but his Rivals are
desperate to catch up what will happen
today well stay tuned and we'll find out
I'm your host International master
yvanka houska and as always great
pleasure to call all the action
alongside the legendary Grandmasters
Judy poga and David Howell oh guys it's
been super excited and due date
yesterday we saw Fabiana Carona Notch up
another classical win what is so
impressive about his play
well he just plays incredibly well very
stable and of course we shouldn't forget
he has an incredible opening preparation
which he built it up in the last several
years also playing in the world
championship match but I think somehow
he's in a great form which is not so
easy to build up your best form
especially for such a tournament but it
seems like he's very calm he's very
balanced he's extremely well prepared
and I can say that I think he's again
extremely motivated um
and David looking to the bottom end of
the tournament five rounds left what can
these players and I'm thinking of big
names such as Magnus Carlsen do to shake
things up yeah I think all of the
chasing pack everyone other than Fabi
they need to start taking even more
risks we've seen the players play really
Fighting Chess so far but it's all about
the classical portion the likes of
Magnus Carson he's won three
armageddon's but that's only good enough
for eighth place out of ten he needs to
win in the classical and at this point
they need to yeah go all in they if they
want to catch Fabi yeah Fabby does seem
Unstoppable and let's take a recap of
yesterday's pairings it was such
incredible day of chess with four out of
five encounters heading to Armageddon
and there we can see at the top of the
table Magnus Carlson walking away with
an Armageddon win but he had to use all
his wits to defeat 17 year old good cash
what other moments caught your eye there
do it
well of course all the games are
extremely interesting well of course the
Fabiano game is very obvious because I
think that that was kind of the the game
of the tournament so far but for example
it was very interesting also to see tari
playing against Wesley so the classical
game he was not so he couldn't show his
uh his real strengths I think because of
the opening and then he was kind of
playing for a draw but it was very
interesting that he missed one move win
versus Wesley so so that was a great
miss by him and I think it's interesting
how he will recover and for you David
what struck you about yesterday's games
yeah for me it was those two kind of
generational clashes firstly as you
mentioned kukash against Carlson just
the different styles the way they
approached the game good cash being
maybe a bit more direct really well
prepared Magnus trying to kind of Dodge
and duck and dive around uh just to try
and survive and persevere in the
Armageddon and also Fabby just using all
of his experience there to defeat
farouza just really classy uh game
followed by great Killer Instinct from
our leader and that great Killer
Instinct led to Fabiano becoming well
skyrocketing up the standings so let's
take a look there fabulous Fabi with a
magnificent 10 and a half points out of
12. oh the looking insurmountable and
then in second place we have Hikaru
Nakamura with six and a half points out
of 12 alireza there in third place six
points big difference between Fabiano
and the chase impact and another
standout name is in eighth place Magnus
Carlson with just four and a half points
out of 12. but still five rounds left
everything to play for and as David
mentioned it's all about winning in the
classical games and today's matchups
whoa we have as always a big treat lined
up Magnus Carlson against Anish giri
remember Anish giri did beat Magnus
Carlson earlier on the year in tata
steel what other encounters are you
eagerly anticipating during it well one
of my favorite Encounter of today is the
two youngster between nodier back and
gokash because I'm very excited to see
their development and it's very clear at
this age they just have so much energy
and appetite for chess that from one day
to another they can improve a lot and
thank you David uh yeah it's the clash
between Hikaru Nakamura we've deemed him
our fourth commentator thanks to his
stints in the confessional booth and
he's facing birthday boy Aryan tari 24th
birthday here obviously Nakamura starts
his big favorite but for tari can he get
a birthday present that's the big
question well we'll find out today
that's for sure and of course no HS is
the home of Fighting Chess and what
makes it unique is its tournament format
it's really never ever been done before
and it pushes the limits of Chess in
every possible way and there we can see
it's a template a single round robin 120
minutes for the entire game sounds like
a lot it really isn't and this is the
key part 10 second increment added after
the players have reached move 40 and in
the case of a draw this is an OHS
specialty Armageddon will break the tie
and of course Fighting Chess means no
drill offers before move 30. and there
we can see the players they are sitting
there ready alireza fuja getting ready
to face off against Wesley so and whoa
looking very serious aren't they
yeah I think because we are reaching the
halfway Park uh kind of point now in the
tournament they realize that it's
business time they need to start winning
farrugia he's only had decisive games up
to this point so far uh all decided In
classical so
um yeah he's he's come fighting uh
Wesley of course he knows what to do Mr
pragmatic uh very hard to beat there and
now we see Hikaru against tari uh it
doesn't look like he's celebrating his
birthday uh too enthusiastically so far
Ariane hits down to business uh we often
say there's a curse over players when
they have their birthday it's often hard
to focus on the chess but of course it's
even harder when you have a Titan like
Hikaru Nakamura sitting opposite you
yeah interestingly enough
um Ari antaria actually copied hikaru's
approach in yesterday's game against
Wesley so you know he opened up with a
marshall just like Hikaru did against
Magnus and just like Hikaru did against
Magnus he paid the Armageddon with a
king's Gambit
yeah we love to see it well King's
Gambit is always fun to see but it's not
always so successful as the player who
plays it with like it to happen
of course at this level the players are
not preparing every day against the
king's Gambit but somewhere
deep they generally speaking they know
that it can happen on the board but if
you have the right mindset and some some
preparation then they are not going to
be
slipping and having a bad position
already out of the opening with black
and what predictions do you have for
this particular encounter Magnus against
the niche well all I know is that Magnus
will be desperate for Revenge having
lost their last classical encounter in
January uh Magnus means business as well
so far struggling to get off the
scoreboard in the classical portion of
the event uh Magnus will go all out for
the win here I don't think he'll be
taking the safety first approach and it
just I think it depends on how Anish
emerges out of the opening if we reach a
solid position a niche will be thrilled
how about you Judith I have a feeling
that Anish is pretty nervous in this
game he knows exactly as well I think
that Magnus will go all out he has to
win and he has to win the classical and
there we see Magnus opening with D4
Anisha actually developing the night
what can we expect from a niche
something solid to take it to Armageddon
I think Anisha will be Rock Solid it's
true to his style Judith noted a pattern
in anisha's play this tournament he
loves to get the Queens off as early as
possible maybe I'll not get the Queen's
off in this game I think in the opening
what are we going to see D5 and Catalan
from Magnus that has been his go-to
weapon of late in the last few years
with white
and there we go he pushes the g-pawn
getting ready to feed and cut to his
Bishop it's the Catalan it he started to
play Catalan on your advice or your
influence David I I must admit I did
advise him to use different move orders
to get to the Catalan because I've
always been too lazy to calculate all
these detect C4 variations of Bishop B4
check but we have discussed certain
lines of the Catalan of course it was
his main repertoire in the 2021 World
Championship as well when he faced off
against the under pomnishi and there he
tried a few different ideas as white but
this position Rock Solid and Niche also
an expert in these variations in these
lines of course he was playing it
against Fabiano if I remember well just
in the Armageddon game which did not
turn out to be successful for him but I
think catalani is an opening which is
loved by many of the players I remember
from the really old timer like anatolic
harpov he was playing it against me
quite a few times
yeah and uh what do we think about this
move from Magnus
very daring right to play the night out
to C3
yeah and this often entails the porn
sacrifice usually White's Queen goes
hunting for that uh black C4 Pawn this
is uh kind of a branch of the Queen's
Gambit a black has said okay I'm going
to take your pawn and try and cling onto
it for a little while at least and
Knight C3 says okay I'm just going to
develop and try to occupy the center now
Black's main move I believe is Knight to
C6 and Anish was reaching for one of his
Queen side pieces
uh what will Anish go for here this is
still a very trendy line
um I've seen another back employ this
recently with a lot of success
well as we know these days giving up a
pawn and just play for positioner play
also it's very fashionable but of course
in the Catalan it happens quite often
that you don't pay attention that much
on the C4 pawn and once the Knight gets
to E5 the G2 fianchetto Bishop opens up
and there can be put quite a lot of
pressure on Black's position
so I'm I think we can expect a nice
sharp long game here yeah and it's
interesting to see anisha's body
language just head in hands kind of
reached out for the piece retracted his
hand reached out again kind of pausing
uh just trying to memorize everything or
maybe he knows two or three different
lines here for black and he's just
trying to choose which one Magnus will
be least prepared against uh really
interesting here I remember Magnus
beating Anisha in the Catalan a couple
of times so maybe a good choice from
White
to me how does one approach facing a
player as well prepared as a niche
because Magnus has chosen the Catalan
it's a tried and tested opening
everything has been played and it's not
going to come as a surprise to a niche
either because one just has to look at
magnus's world championship match
against Nyan to see okay it's very much
in his repertoire and David as you
indicated black has also developed the
Knight to C6 putting pressure on the D4
point and okay
lots of games and this database I have
in front of me 94 games and
well main move is actually to to I was
going to say support the pawn Center but
Magnus playing in a much more
enterprising way and taking control of
the center by advancing that pawn two
squares forward
yeah and uh Magnus has played a lot of
variations like this firstly in the
Catalan also in these kind of
symmetrical grunfeld positions where he
just gives up opponency for and instead
of the traditional methods of
recapturing that pawn just takes the
space as you said Judith uh engines kind
of
that really like it maybe as much as
some other lines but there's nothing
wrong with it objectively and uh of
course if it has surprise value that's a
bit of a bonus and I do have a feeling
initial start to think now I must admit
E4 to me it's uh I'm not sure whether I
have looked at it if I have it's been
too long ago to remember anything here
yes because in the Catalan generally
speaking when you have the fiancato
bishop on G2 you like it when it's open
right that's why it's there to have such
a great power under the diagonal and
when you play E4 it's kind of blocking
the G two Bishop at the same time it's
taking control over the center it
weakens the D3 Square so this is
something else I remember once I had the
Catalan game versus Ivan Chuck back in
Linares many many years ago at least
like 20 years ago or something and once
I I was able to jump into D3
and somehow things turned out very
positively very short game against
ivanchukai one but of course it's not so
easy to get to D3
um yeah one thing that I I have as a
general rule in these type of positions
is that when white puts the Knight on C3
black just holds on to the pawn on C4 so
I mean the moves that I'd be playing is
like Rook B8 to try to get B5 in and
just sit there and say I have that extra
material and now you do what you like
with your space I'm just surviving yeah
but you're always grabbing pawns and
skipping bones right you make sure it's
not the debate and it's not a question
but of course rugby is a very logical
continuation exactly because if white
would not given up a pawn then white
would have a great position right but
the question is whether the compensation
how much it's going to be shown in the
game and indeed many times after such a
sacrifice on C4 and having the D4 and C4
D4 and E4 Pawn white is not getting back
does not have the opportunity to grab
back the C4 Pawn
well we'll see how
yeah we'll see how this develops also
a6b5 makes a lot of sense I believe to
play A6 B5 Bishop B7 so to protect the
pawn from with the opponent A6 because
white not necessarily would like to play
A4 because then the B4 Square would get
a great weakness yeah well certainly it
looks like it's going to be a tense
battle shall we go back to the bird's
eye view and have a brief look at the
other games
yeah let's have a recap on how the
opening phases are panning out so far uh
or already one game catches my eye I
must admit and that is
with our leader but uh still early days
in all of the other clashes of course
yes uh certainly and uh everyone looks
like they are in for the mood for a
fight and I'm also another game that
catches my eye is the game between the
youngsters nordebec Abdus Turf actually
launching forward with the g2 Pawn to G4
that's very enterprising it's a very
scary movie your favorite move yeah if I
remember well either in this position or
something very similar position one of
the first was to play from the top guys
it was mommy jarov it is a typical such
an energetic kind of crazy in a positive
way move and actually we are not
surprised to see this move on the board
and uh was there some players who have
come to the game in a fighting mood I
mean the others have have quieter
positions on the board and looking at
Hikaru Nakamura against the birthday boy
Aryan tari looks very normal but uh what
is Hikari planning and uh perhaps we
should actually go to Hikaru who caught
up with swara for his pregame insights
you're playing another Norwegian today
what do you feel about the game in
advance yeah I mean I have the white
pieces for one of the few times in the
tournament so far um obviously RN's very
strong player a little bit unlucky in
some of his games in the early part of
the tournament um yeah I'll try to play
my best and we'll see what happens
you've been doing a lot of different
roles during this tournament you've been
doing a live commentator you've been
pretty much hosting the shows you've
been playing chess and you've been doing
analysis of all the games are you trying
to put everyone in the TV industry out
of a job
um well it's not the intention but I
think I'm pretty pretty good at it I've
had a couple of years of a Non-Stop
experience so just trying to make it
interesting and I think you know one
thing I heard is that like unload the
camera at a lot of the same same
thoughts that I did so it seems like at
least the top players we all have we all
view the game pretty much in a similar
way and I think just it's it's good
overall um because people are interested
in what we think I mean I'm waiting for
Magnus to do that too but he hasn't done
it so far I don't think we're looking
forward to the game again sorry and good
luck to you thank you
[Laughter]
and banned after all our jobs what do we
think about that
you can have it he's better at me than
this so we love to hear his thoughts
right we love to absolutely I'm looking
forward to have at least the two or
three confessional booths uh making full
round what is really going on on this
run and it's quite amazing that he has a
very good sense of natural talent in
this that he he has a very quick Vision
to see what's going on on the other
board though I wonder how he can manage
to do all these things well most of the
time I see him sitting at his board
yeah just incredible stamina just to
kind of play such a long game every day
and then go back and still produce these
YouTube kind of Recaps I guess that's
why he Magnus and the others they're so
consistent just because they love chess
and that's all they do every day you
know I was thinking about it when I was
still in competition after every game I
had my I went back to my computer I
looked but also I was writing down like
a diary kind of thing what I was
thinking and of course also analyzing it
when there was no engine still only my
thoughts after the game and discussing
with the opponent so somehow I had the
feeling that maybe this is something
similar to him because for me it was
important that after the game I close it
in my mind where I made the mistake what
has happened what I should have done and
after that I could focus on the next
game so somehow I feel that maybe Hikaru
also when he goes back to his hotel room
and he makes this recap of 15-20 minutes
somehow he makes a summary for the
audience and for his fans but also for
him somehow it layers up summarizes it
for himself where I made a mistake and
then I go for dinner and then I go for
the next game yeah
therapeutic yeah it certainly is
therapeutic and one thing that Hikaru
himself said that he actually finds
streaming and producing these YouTube
videos as liberating you know for him he
can be himself he can sit there and just
kind of see the bigger picture in some
ways because yes you know ultimately if
he lost it's not that big of a deal you
know because he can go back and like you
say use it as therapy
well of course we are very fortunate I
think that we have a top player in the
world who feels very strong for the
audience and for the fans and he feels
extremely comfortable doing so and we
don't see him at the war so maybe maybe
maybe already now he's making his first
tour checking what the other games are
going on yeah wow
if this happens we will go to all man on
the board
and we'll let him take it away because
his insights are golden you know what I
want to see from Hikaru today I want to
hear Hikaru singing happy birthday to
his opponent in the confessional booth
for Arianda maybe he doesn't know that
it's his birthday oh maybe better not to
know otherwise you feel generous you
feel bad for your opponents if it's
their birthday at least I do you know I
didn't I didn't see the players being
generous at the chess board I was gonna
call David out as well I've never met a
grand master he's like oh it's his
birthday let me just give them a draw
they're like nope
you can suffer if you want to take a
draw from me and this is the physician
we have it's only move five in the clash
between Hikaru Nakamura and ariantari
and it is a Kingsport opening it's The
Bishop's opening I'm not even sure what
to call this it's kind of a hybrid
opening and White's last move is
dropping the bishop back to B3 and uh
yeah it's interesting just a few months
ago in the Norwegian League actually
sitting next to Ariane there was an
interesting game which came up to this
point and instead of Bishop B3 white
played the move F4 for ambitious yes and
white was duly punished so uh by aryan's
coach and uh Aryans or one of aryan's
former coaches he said this line is
great for black after C6 black is better
and I thought this can't be true but
clearly if arian's former coach said
that then uh he must know a thing or two
and Bishop B3 just preemptively getting
out the way of black striking in the
center with D5 When I See This variation
I have to give a shout out to the
sausage Sussex Junior kids who all
employed this
I mean whatever Jenna generation they
are all playing this so big hello too
and big thank you to Jonathan tuck yeah
I think you even played this David uh
from time to time I used to play like
this when I was younger it's just very
simple to remember to just bring the
bishop out uh kind of get ready to play
F4 very early and like you say there's a
whole generation of kids in England who
this is their bread and butter they
probably know far more than we do in
this position but meanwhile D6 does that
surprise you dude that black just
pushing the pawn one square instead of
trying to fight for the center
well the five somehow looks a logical
move after in this position but after
Bishop B3 white probably has something
in mind taking on D5 or playing Bishop
G5 and somehow to have that pin and put
a lot of pressure on the D5 Square
it it is something I I like for black to
play only to D6 developing opening up
the bishop diagonal also ready to go
Knight bd7 after C6 it's not only
supporting to play B5 but sometimes you
can go B5 or even if white has this
strange idea to play a foot and queen B6
can be unpleasant right so also not G4
at some point can occur
and it seems to be extremely solid black
has a nice position so far that's for
sure yeah and I guess if we think about
it if we flip the board and have reverse
colors if White's Bishop were back on C4
then this is exactly the Italian game
and so basically Ariane he's playing the
Italian game setup with black just well
he's playing it yeah with the colors
reversed so uh really interesting
usually there white is fighting for an
advantage here he's got the exact same
with black of course The Temper down but
yeah he's going to be hoping that that
could translate to something more
tangible maybe a bit later on of course
the C6 Pawn does dominate The Knight on
C3 so black has maybe more opportunities
with pawnbricks in the center
still early days I think we'll come back
to this one a bit later on
so we go to the bird's eye view and have
a look at the other games that are in
play and
I'm very excited by a few of them shall
we first of all check out how tournament
leader Fabiana carono is doing against
one of my most favorite Grandmasters
Shakira Mama jar because oh the position
is hot exactly
this is just crazy stuff this must be
preparation it's so wild at this early
stage we're only at move 16 but the
players are rattling off their moves
white was going for checkmate there this
Pawn imbalances all over the place all
nights off the board already and uh this
is the mess that we see in front of us
uh should we do a recap to see how we
got here
let's go from move one it was the
English opening making me and Ivanka
very proud here very patriotic the
English opening and after C4 E5
it was the variation with all the nights
coming out four nights and E4 this was
seen in the world championship match
between Ding and janapomnishi Knight
takes E5 now a nice tricky move here
tricking the Black Knight forward so
that white can initiate this Fork White
will regain the piece and after d takes
Knight takes E4 black winning the pawn
back level material Now with an ice pin
white has this move Queen to F3 which
was introduced by Magnus Carlson against
Fabiana karawana in the grand Swiss in
2019 and now rather than playing Knight
takes Knight which we saw in that world
championship match uh Jan taking the
knights and retreating his Bishop D5
from Mama jarov fighting move in the
center I must admit I'm not too familiar
with this I know D5 was playable but it
led to some chaos and this must be the
chaos that has happened just Bishop E2
and look at this D4 from ahmadiarov
these players have done their homework
utilizing the pin but giving up the
Black Knight for the White Knight and
after White Castles castles A3 we see
another trade of Pawns the bishop drops
back white lining up and Checkmate now
on H7 this is fast stuff of course there
are options but really nice aggressive
play here forcing G6 and E6 Tudor
lining up a nasty Checkmate along this
diagonal it seems like Mama jarov is
absolutely in his home preparation as he
instantly went Queen E7
it's very important to defend the bishop
on C5 so after Queen E5 it's not a
double attack attacking the bishop and
the Checkmate on G7 so black and go F6
and after that black would take the E6
spawn so Queen E5 would be something not
good for white I believe that white will
have to grab on F7
or maybe it's also possible to play a
bit Queen F4
by the way what about Rook ae1
instead of moving the queen wow with the
idea that if Bishop E6 then Queen E5
right so that would win material
here Black's Bishop will drop off the
board
wow this is so scary for black I've got
to say absolutely and if Queen E6
then I would be going maybe between H4
attacking the queen
I don't know what to play here Queen D6
for example yeah maybe between D6 so
after Queen H6 Bishop D4 yeah but
something feels a bit smelly for black
could you go Bishop F6 so that you meet
nice Queen takes D3 the White Queen will
come in with a nasty Checkmate what's
the name of this Checkmate
um kiss of death I think it's like
Lolly's Checkmate but uh I don't know
whether lollies is with just the pawn
but anyhow
yeah this position just looks too scary
for black surely okay so let's see after
Rook ae1 what black can do
wow
I mean okay you don't want to play a
move like F6 you block the diagonal but
you leave white with this huge passport
on E6
could you Corral that pawn though and
but it's very difficult to even develop
the light Square bishop and The Rook on
A8 so no that gets my veto
um but maybe you
I would just resign here
okay he plays this almost identical idea
yeah maybe he wanted to make sure the A3
Pawn is protected oh wow I forgot that
that one was uh even on the board I saw
it on it was attacked I just didn't
believe it that it's possible to capture
it and then I would rather have my other
Rook on F1 defending the F2 yeah exactly
ivanka's rubbing off on you her
influence uh the pawn grabbing
Bishop takes A3 if the white Rook had
moved away from A1 but now like you say
Judith there's gonna be ideas against
this Pawn for example uh in some lines
you can maybe not now but you can start
thinking about F takes E6 and uh taking
on F2 yeah but maybe the idea is of
Fabiano that if black is taking on E6
he's making so much damage in the in the
king's side and also blocking the C8
Bishop then after that anything probably
rookie too I mean compensation forever
that's for sure and maybe you can just
go Queen E5 anyway and give up the
material yeah even in this position it
needs to be calculated Queen E5 Bishop
takes F2 and we just hide and there's
all sorts of threats against this black
king
pewter of course the evaluation file
will say 0.0 but if Mama jarv hasn't
analyzed this hasn't studied it doesn't
know exactly what to do then it could
well lead into lead to disaster uh over
the next few moves this just looks
terrifying for black well it's
definitely something extremely sharp and
in the next three four moves it has to
be seen whether black is balancing or
black has a huge trouble
because right now it looks one thing is
sure it looks very scary
yeah and this is where preparation can
be treacherous sometimes it's better to
know nothing than something because
mamajarov he's paused for the first time
in this game and if Rook to E1 wasn't on
his radar in his preparation then he
might start to panic I know I would at
least well that would be very scary if
Fabiano's home preparation will work and
he would let's say uh make a quick win
because that it's really like he is a
racket no stop yeah it's like a dream
isn't it
um so I I turned on the engine just to
say I wanted to to check how narrow is
the path for Shaq and his computer's top
move is A5 what yeah okay six of course
I thought about that with F6 but I only
in that in that kind of aspect um second
move is Pawn takes F E6 yeah so 0.6 E6
is probably what he's calculating but it
just looks so scary that's the thing and
maybe he'll come to the conclusion
there's nothing else five that's yeah
superhuman uh kind of restraint
the only way he'll find that is if maybe
he's seen a similar idea in his
preparation but I think it's it's
incredibly scary if you're out of book
and out of your preparation in this
position playing against Fabi
um it's one of the most unpleasant
situation what can be I mean look at
that Bishop on B2 it's just ready to get
the support for the queen and give
Checkmate and development is much better
for white so A5
I've been in this situation myself just
uh when I last played Fabi in a
classical game in the grand Swiss I
thought I prepared the variation of my
life I've prepared 20 something moves
and then of course he went one move
deeper I sat there thinking I know the
computer says 0.0 but why it looks like
I'm lost and of course within three or
four moves I was indeed lost uh he just
knows everything to the end and after
the game we discussed he was like oh you
know you could have done this this this
it leads to this queen sacrifice and a
four straw and I was like okay I was
never gonna get this and that's the
problem with going through these
computer lines he knows the human aspect
as well and uh he goes deeper than a lot
of the top GMS that was my experience as
well with Fabiano you know because we I
managed to survive the opening I don't
know how but I did but uh what struck me
was that
I was just kind of playing my intuitive
chess and he had calculated out a
sacrifice that I had on the board you
know he'd finished it to the conclusion
and I think a lot of people would have
just gone no that's just way too scary
for me to play with my king out there in
the open but Fabi was like nope
needs must and I will do what the
position demands I was very impressed by
that his calculation is is really
extremely strong
I started to look at the A5 can we go
into this yeah let's go in A5 because
it's interesting that I think black will
not take on E6 but it can easily happen
that the F2 is weak because white will
have to capture on F7 though I think
it's uh I don't think we can take void
white and F7 because Rook takes F7
and white cannot uh
go away from the exchange because
otherwise Queen D5 Bishop F2
yeah a Quinn trade will more than suit
black I think black will be very safe if
the Queens disappear from the board so
if white cannot take on F7 this is the
idea playing Queen F4 or queen F3
but before maybe yeah again this might
lead to that variation we mentioned uh
Judith if black does get uh kind of
greedy now and take on E6 we're
basically committed as white to going in
to try and get through this diagonal and
we're committed to this exchange
sacrifice which might just be very good
for white but thus A5 makes all the
difference
because the Rook on asia8 can come and
assist the king 20 moves down the line
I'm sorry I can sometimes is the case
ah and uh Fabi most likely knows exactly
what's going on in both of these lines
Bishop takes E1 let's try and follow it
through firstly do we jump in or do we
uh do we just take there is no reason to
rush so what about taking though maybe
after rookie one king F7 will be the
move
ah King F7
or still feels scary somehow
yeah the king wants to hide back on its
starting Square on E8
yeah you're right Judith maybe the king
just hides now uh let's go back and see
let's investigate what happens if I do
get greedy instead of taking this bishop
if I check but the thing is if you take
a queen h8 I think F7 takes on H7 King
E8 can you avoid the queen Exchange
maybe not the problem is after Bishop
takes porn the king Heights on d8 and a
check can be blocked by the other Bishop
probably one yeah suddenly the king
hides and there's a rook F1 in the air
as well so
whoops tricky tricky stuff
and this is the type of thing that's
going through Shaq's mind right now of
course uh he's gonna see these
variations that we do but he also knows
that Fabiano knows the truth and that's
the hardest thing such a nice movie it
just doesn't work and Shaq he's a genius
so creative he does find the top
computer choice of A5
The Rook is coming so white needs
something quick actually I still believe
that it's home prep for both do you
think so
I have a feeling Shaq knew that A5 was a
possible move either in this exact
position or in similar positions and
yeah if you know that the idea exists if
you can't see anything wrong with it he
can go for it
we can find it he's a player who can
find such a move
but uh but still he he spent only like
12 minutes
so it's kind of uh tricky we discussed
it yesterday that when you know your
prep you know the line are you still
spending some time hesitating thinking
about other options
uh convince yourself that it's going to
be okay or whatever and uh talking about
preparation I would be very interested
to get your thoughts on two positions uh
the first one I'm gonna ask are grunfeld
experts as between Wesley so and alireza
faroogia what do we think are these
players treading well trodden paths and
it's gonna head into a very simple draw
or
do you want the good news or the bad
news
bad news first okay the bad news uh for
farouja fans maybe is that he doesn't
often employ the grinfeld and actually
after he went for the grinfeld on move
three Wesley went into a long long think
uh and it this is one of the main lines
of the exchange variation in the
grinfeld and far Asia the fact that he's
been thinking for a long time means he's
maybe unaware of some small details of
the nuances
um
yeah that's the bat well actually maybe
that's the good news
even I'm getting confused here the good
news is that farucha isn't 100 sure and
of course will want to fight uh so maybe
he'll try and keep the game going the
bad news is Wesley has employed this
exact variation multiple times and every
time it seems to lead to a fourth draw
um maybe we'll put some variations on
the board shortly but I think we might
well see it play out well this is our
Theory yeah this has been heavily
analyzed it's just both of them are
trying to recall the lines which to
choose how to try to post problem to the
other one but there is a great chance to
see an armor this isn't the wimp Mill
variation is it it is I've never heard
that name before uh Ivanka the wimp Mill
it was coined by Simon Williamson one of
our shows that's because later on white
has this windmill technique of checking
on G7 with the white Rook then going
away then coming back to G7 it's like a
windmill you go back and forth and it
ends in a repetition and moves
and uh yeah I'm trying to figure out I'm
trying to remember how it's gone because
it's been years since I've studied this
variation I was also playing it with
black I remember once uh playing against
Boris girlfriend he was really the the
maybe the biggest expert at the time
back 96 or so
and I was very proud I said if I want to
make I have to prove that I'm really
there in the top I have to fight in the
field where they're experts so this is
what happened and then I I made a very
interesting game and it was draw equal
it was a good game and did that strategy
work out for you
well sometimes it's the case when you
want to stop level up on the next stage
then you have to fight on the territory
what where your opponent is the best
interesting because I've I've spent my
life avoiding that where possible and I
tried to create my own stronghold so but
also when you have no choice like I was
a gruntful player at the time and also
Kings and then of course but he was also
an expert in King's Indian so I said
okay King's in there and he knows too
much with white and black color and I
know that objectively of course if
you're very well prepared then you can
get in trouble so groomfield was a more
sound opening which I was playing
already and I said okay expert expert I
understand but I have to do my job and I
have to face in in this battle and how
many hours did you dedicate to actually
mastering an opening such as the
grunfeld
depends how much it fits you to your
style also but of course when it gets
very concrete and in the Grim Felder
endless lines to to work on I mean move
seven there are deviations many many
different lines so you have to know your
opponent how and which direction he is
going so against Boris I didn't have to
work so much before the game but of
course when you develop a new opening
depending on the opening you have to
understand many things the Strategic
part the patterns the middle game
understanding also what is the outcome
in the structure in an end game you have
to look all the the model games and then
it comes to the concrete moves
okay well interesting here looks like
this is Mainline stuff shall we move on
to a different game or yeah I agree
we'll move on we'll see how farugia
developed here I'm expecting the move uh
Rook a to B8
um as at least back in the day when I
used to play this position that was the
move I used to play but uh yep may be
unaware of all the nuances not this uh
not his home ground here uh what will he
go for that's the question okay and uh
finally I've been having Twitchy fingers
about this position for a long long time
it's the matchup between nordebec Abdus
because uh nordebec just employed one of
the trickiest lines against the sami's
love and almost this line has kind of
been forgotten about and it's
occasionally wheeled out as a surprise
yeah I agree I've been playing the this
line a bit myself as black and once I
think the most recent time I played uh
the slav I realized at the board that G4
was an option and I hadn't looked at it
ever and uh luckily my opponent didn't
play it there but uh this is really
ambitious stuff from Abdul sotorov let's
go back from move one this is the
current position on move 12 now as you
can see it's chaotic with white spawns
in the center White's Rook what's that
doing on G4 you might ask so let's see
how we got here uh we did start with one
D4 and uh by transposition we got to the
slav it started as a queen Scamper
declined and here C6 transposes back and
after E3 Knight D7 Queen C2 we see G4 on
the board and uh this is based on the
idea that after Knight takes G4 uh
accepting the Gambit Rook to G1 if the
Black Knight moves away then the pawn on
G7 is no longer defended because Black's
Bishop has vacated the f8 square so
black fights fire with fire doesn't back
down Queen 6 counter-attacking hitting
the undefended White Knight and after a
capture of both knights we see H3 just
very quiet move there I guess the H Pawn
was hanging and after Queen to F6 this
is a proper Pawn sacrifice now for white
E4 initiating chaos and H5 so a hit on
the white Rook but the big question is
firstly can white get away with a move
like E5 can white get away with a move
like Bishop G5 or does white simply have
to retreat and step away with that piece
where to even begin analyzing this one
exactly that is a very pertinent
question so I think it's the perfect
time to leave everyone on a big Cliff
hammer and take a quick break and in the
meantime we do have to mention that
there is a fantastic chance and
opportunity for you all and don't miss
your chance to win Diamond membership
this Friday the chess.com Discord server
is hosting an arena with four Diamond
memberships up for grabs to stake your
claim join the Discord at go.chess.com
forward slash Discord then head over to
go.chess.com forward slash connect and
connect your account and you're done you
can now compete in the weekly arena for
our Discord community and win free
Diamond membership use x-clam Discord in
chat now and we'll be back with more
chess right after our first break don't
go anywhere
foreign
chess.com's game review recently got a
major update here are four key notes at
the end of each game review you will now
see a summary of the game from your
coach your performance rating for that
game and a quick grade for you and your
opponent in the opening middle game and
end game we've added a new
classification called Miss for when a
move fails to take advantage of an
opportunity but it is otherwise a sound
move we've also changed the definition
of blunder now a move will only be
considered a blunder if it loses
material or allows a Checkmate coach
will now draw arrows and highlight
squares when you hover over or click on
the highlighted words in the move
explanations this should make move
explanations easier to follow finally
coach's explanations will now reference
specific pieces and threads in
explanations making move explanations
much more intuitive the new game review
experience is available chess.com right
now
[Music]
foreign
welcome back and we did leave you on a
cliffhanger as we were exploring the
position between nordebec abdusotoff and
gukash so let's cut straight to the
Chase and dive into all the action on
that board
and what are we thinking the position is
still wild the position is still wild I
asked a big question what to do with
white after Black's last move kicking
away the white rook and nodabek answered
that question in the break he simply
stepped back to G2 a retreating move and
go cash answers very quickly there
Bishop to F4 getting out of the way of
any hits with those Central white pawns
and Judith I need help here black is
important up but everything's happening
in the center absolutely there was a
huge question whether E5 was possible or
not but for another wreck it was clear
that he wants to keep the tension in the
center he rather has more pawns than an
extra
peace because probably he could he could
go for a piece
oh it's a big question whether white now
I would rather play E5 or maybe he is
going to be exchanging the piece on F4
and uh and then somehow keep the
pressure also the question is what about
taking and take on G7 grabbing back upon
lots of questions we have to jump in
here the position is so concrete it's so
forcing that the players will be
calculating a load right now and after
Bishop takes F4 let's check this one out
through that uh Bishop takes F4 Queen
takes F4 Rook takes G7 regains the pawn
regains the material means the black
king will never ever Castle kingside not
sure it wanted to anyway but uh what
could black reply with here it looks
very healthy to me well it's one thing
to talk about the black skin not costly
but white can say the same thing right
we cannot Castle now with the queen on
F4 yeah the question is now how black is
going to be developing his pieces and
possibly one day he he would like to
Castle alongside
it takes a long time black needs to move
the Knight he then needs to move the
bishop out the way then needs to Castle
uh at least for white if you kick the
black queen away you are ready so I
quite like this I've got to say it looks
like uh I mean quite a safe line for
white I don't see any downsides but
let's see what happens if D takes E4
and let's say after Knight E4 Black Goes
Knight F6 right to eliminate the very
active Knight on e4
it makes a lot of sense you know blackis
in a great deal of danger and you've got
to play that Knight F6 move otherwise C5
will cement the D6 Square
and only one ambitious move to keep the
knights on the board I'm a bit worried
it feels a bit loose for white but let's
try Knight G5 I knew it out
but after an ig5 I think Rook f8
defending the F7 pawn and it's very
important that for the moment white
cannot put into safety his King long
Castle
hmm
yeah I'm trying to make something work
with uh taking on S7 and queen to G6 but
it never quite uh comes in here
but maybe you don't need to make
anything work maybe you can just sit
like when thinking of
G2 or something
yeah I can develop the bishop and uh I
guess black will try to at some point
Play Bishop D7 in Castle but it takes a
long long time
oh this position is so tense oh well
maybe after Bishop G2 Bishop D7 Knight
F7 might be a move
six F7 with the idea that Rook takes F7
Queen she's six and there's some kind of
chaos happening here isn't yeah
but maybe not G4 yeah Knight G4 and
black gives back a piece but black is
also hitting the F2 Pawn uh with the
queen suddenly and this counter attack
looks like it might backfire on white
suddenly there is another way of trying
for white maybe to take C takes D5 in
the position what we have at the on the
board
with the idea if he takes D5 then then
E5 so then somehow the bone structure
seems to be better for white or if C
takes D5 then some point Knight B5 can
be unpleasant
the White Knight maybe now or in the
next few moves can start using this uh
this Square as a launch pad also now
black will never ever cast a queen side
because there will be uh something on
the C file yeah I'm not sure I want to
open up this black Bishop though that's
the only downside now if the Knight
comes out the way then this black Bishop
might be very well placed on C8 after E5
then okay I keep my Bishop defended
I'm just thinking if I get one more move
Knight B6 or Knight f8 or something then
black I don't think it will be worse
or shouldn't be worse everything covered
yeah because the default Pawn is
dropping off the bishop takes Bishop
yeah suddenly this Pawn might be loose
as well
it had really tense position if we go
back to the game uh then I'm just trying
to think are there actually any options
if we do play E5 immediately of course
the same thing black plays Queen H6 and
again unless we trade now and go for the
G7 Pawn then
what next
suddenly I'm struggling to see the
alternatives for white
feels like black has got enough
defensive resources there but I think
Envy Chuck wants more Bishop F4 takes
the Rook G7 because after they takes E4
I would be taking it with the queen I
think aha
yeah slightly counterintuitive but maybe
in this exact position it's more
annoying that Black's Queen is so active
removing Black's best piece and there
are threats like Knight D6
but once the king steps to f8
let's say
and
and the PC square is it's it's
vulnerable isn't it you know you can
just see a situation with C5 and Knight
D6 and White's pieces have the greater
Freedom yeah this can be unpleasant so
maybe after Queen E4 or D takes E4 maybe
not to move in F6 was possible to attack
on the G7 rook and the D4 Pawn
and now the white Rook will be forced
back I'm not sure where this time let's
say I go the whole way back just for
argument's sake maybe not the best way
yeah maybe G3 I was one G3 so after
Queen d4c takes D5 and D takes D5 I was
slightly worried you would hit me here
with the pawn but now I can move again
Rook E3 brick somewhere yeah I'm just
happy to be on the e-file yeah
developing across the board makes a lot
of sense who needs to Castle when you
can develop a rook like this and what
about I know it's like so risky
okay I was gonna suggest C5 but I don't
know that really is bad in this exact
position in this exact position only for
tactical reasons but uh I realize it's
so risky I think he takes C5 enough to
see the Knight D4 comes with it yeah
that would be the first thing I would
thing but maybe yeah
I like how the evaluation part is always
tricking us a firm judge you know oh no
not good
um but but one thing that I do know in
these type of positions because is that
when the white Rook comes to G7 you tend
to go
King f8 to hide your king there and then
you centralize your queen and you you
prepare for the end game that way maybe
King f8 is the kind of efficient way to
kick back this Rook while not recruiting
The Black Queen keeping her active
stopping white from Castle in greenside
but maybe something similar will happen
there White's Retreats and again it's up
to Black to decide how to release the
pressure I think either way now Abdul
sotorov in the game position
the only thing we've seen so far is
taking this bishop and taking this Pawn
back restoring the material balance and
still some questions for black to answer
their cash solid as black but
it feels like that's the most practical
way to do it oh there is still another
idea I would come off with for white
what happens if white takes on D5 C
takes D5
I'll take back
and
what about E5 now
I will move
question is what next
I just yeah I can't get it out of my
mind the fact that Black's night if it
ever gets around to E6 well it's one F4
I go Knight E2 okay everything was Tempo
let's say I go back
I just want to stay on this diagonal to
stop you from F4 I think oh
coming at me now
and let's say I move my knight somewhere
I'm not sure where I want to go F5 too
much you go on IC 493 maybe I come in
maybe it's just very concrete if I
didn't have this move Knight C4 maybe
you just Steamroller me but here
definitely you have to guard the squares
that you leave behind when you push
pawns
um is there is one alternative which is
like we've been looking at like pushing
the pawn to E5 what happens if you just
accelerated the play completely by
exchanging all the Pawns
taking everything in the center here
also a good question I do wonder where
the black castles
well maybe just Castle now yeah castling
into the line of fire but suddenly
White's King is also maybe living a
Charmed Life regretting the decision to
open up lines in the center white can't
castle and for now Black's King safe so
yeah very good question Ivanka I mean
this is one of the things the players
will be calculating for sure but at the
same time it looks extremely open for a
white with a white King right and also
black has uh has a nice active situation
and if he is ready to go back to Knight
B6 open up the C8 Bishop then it can be
also
very much double edged definitely
yeah so let's await that decision from
Abdul sotorov one thing I wanted to
mention as well is that these guys have
history uh actually the Olympiad last
year was decided pretty much in this
individual Clash when gokash was
completely winning outplayed Abdul
sotorov but then failed to find The
Knockout blow and suddenly things
started turning turning turning and go
cash blundered Abdul satoroff taking the
win and Uzbekistan pretty much pretty
much won the Olympiad because of that
one game so maybe a score to settle
definitely you know I actually asked
about this issue because the two later
played in a championship that I was
commentating at and there you know
kakesh won and we asked him you know
what was it like playing Nordic back do
you mean do you do you want to sit down
and have revenge for that very important
victory that norderbeck had against you
and his reply was so very pragmatic he
just said no you know yes I had that
painful moment against him but I've had
great games against him where I've
enjoyed critical victories because cause
of beating him and so he just said I
don't think about things like that and I
I found that that was a very mature way
for just he was then 16 at the time to
approach things that it was felt very
zen-like
well I think it's important some players
I know that they have this Revenge kind
of feeling
but I think it's it's better to have a
healthy attitude that I mean he can
thank to himself that he made those
mistakes right I mean he created the
winning position and he missed several
opportunities and not only that he
ruined it to draw but he even lost the
game in a very crucial moment but I
think he understood that of course it
was very close to the gold medal if he
wins that with the big group with the
youngsters right but everything is ahead
of him and of course the opponent takes
the opportunity and punishes you for
your mistakes right so he has to he has
to be self-critical in a sense that he
made the mistake next time he has to
correct it and he has to deal with it
within himself not to project it to the
opponent right because there have been
some players in the past who just simply
never gotten over big moments like this
and you know they've come up with
various reasons in their life like why
it didn't work out for them you know
they were arguing with their ex-wife or
they were arguing with their trainer I
mean they were feeling 100 well I mean
so many excuses I remember one special
case when I met Evancho for the first
time back I think it was Lucerne at the
team World Championship back 87 or
something like that and I remember that
Evancho was one of the biggest hope for
the crown after Kasparov and uh and he
was just showing to everybody his Miss
opportunity against Kasparov which he
just played like months ago or something
and he was showing it to everybody look
at this I missed this opportunity I
played such a good game and I think it
took him a lot of energy and time until
he could get over with that but this is
something very important how fast can
you get over on very painful losses even
in very critical positions and critical
moments of your life
yeah one thing I've always failed and
struggled to do but meanwhile we see the
bird's eye view and now we've recapped
to every opening of course games are
developing a pace and
I'm getting uh drawn by the Magnus
Carlson against Anish Gary Clash because
it looks like Magnus who sacrificed a
pawn out of the opening he's given up
another Pawn also a strange inclusion of
H porn pushes in that battle is this
inspiration is this genius by Magnus
Carlson or is it just preparation I
think we have to jump in there to
investigate what's going on
and uh yeah Judith we talked about this
kind of modern strategy of just giving
up upon just playing as if nothing
happened what do you think of this
decision by Magnus to give up his deep
on if black captures
well it's interesting because this is
one of the reason black played Knight C6
immediately
uh that he puts pressure on D4 and
normally you would think that okay tied
down the queen on D1 so white cannot
play Queen E2 because the pawn is
hanging so white has to be playing
Bishop E3 first to protect the D4
opponent only after that the queen can
move out and make a developing move so
now it's a critical moment I think in
the game and we see Anish really having
uh his head in his hands very much
focusing calculating a lot also probably
hesitating how much is it the home
preparation for Magnus how much he
really knows what he's doing and how
good is this idea because many times it
happens that you're just testing your
opponent and if he's playing the best
way it's not going to be anything
special maybe it just goes all the way
to a drawish game it's obviously the
first thing Anisha also has to calculate
what about Knight D4 right that was the
question but I've been waiting for you
to say I've been saying take it away
David show us why
I wish I knew why it looks like a free
porn to me and I'm also a member of the
porn Grabber Society let's bring up a
board just to try and quickly get to the
root of uh of this dilemma does
anishagiri take this Pawn I guess the
alternative is to play the move B5 just
to keep the C4 Pawn intact you cannot
really let that one drop otherwise white
will have the pawn Center the space
Advantage for free so Knight takes pawn
and I'm assuming a trade in the center
and again I'm assuming Rook to D1
kicking away the black queen you can
kick her in different Fashions Bishop to
E3 but then I worry about Queen to D3
just gaining a bit of time threatening a
queen exchange black and Bully white
here a bit because black is temporarily
two pawns up so I don't expect Bishop E3
I'm thinking Rook D1 hitting the black
queen
she steps back she steps away I'm not
sure where let's say C5 another hit and
the question is now what can black do
can you keep this Pawn alive the C4 Pawn
or
yeah or can you uh kind of feel forced
now to put your queen on a really clumsy
Square I'm struggling to find safety
actually I'm looking at this Square B4
I'm looking at the cross this way H5 you
don't really want to go back to C6
because you will get hit along this
diagonal suddenly the Catalan Bishop
opens up
shoot it do you see anything for black
here to make Anish feel confident well I
feel also is the bishop E3 there is
another idea about E5 possibly and the
Black Knight is pushed back and then to
play Bishop F4 and then Knight E4 can
come with huge energy and queen G4 and
there is a Checkmate ideas over there
yeah without the king without the Knight
on F6 looking very scary actually here
for black yeah and Magnus they're
revealing to us that he is a very
fighting mood and incidentally just
before the game svera our reporter
caught up with Magnus and he did hints
foreign
[Music]
and there we see Magnus saying that he
will be trying to win and his play
certainly indicates that putting a niche
Under Pressure right from the get-go
yeah and I'm confused I think if I were
in anisha's shoes as well just looking
at the clock times just looking at the
way the game's gone I would not know
whether Magnus is in preparation or not
and that kind of psychological limbo is
extremely hard if you know your
opponent's in prep at least you can
calculate calculate your way out you
know that they're not bluffing but here
if he senses that Magnus is freestyling
then he might get ambitious himself
anishikiri and that uncertainty is
confusing at the best of times well it
is it can be a big debate with yourself
when you have such a situation I think
that you're continuously well okay there
are two options right it's either
captured upon or I play B5 if I play B5
then there is a little psychological
game what Magnus won that okay I offer
the pony work chicken you didn't take it
you play B5 after that I play Rook D1
and I'm going to put my Bishop to F4 in
one move or just keep it there and give
other threats D5 or or E5 Knight E4
there's also this kind of play and
focusing very much on the king side
and then you're you're hesitating well
come on after all it's a pawn is the
second phone I can take right so let's
calculate it again
and
what did he played B5 he played B5
so psychological loss there you think
for Anish
well it's difficult to say whether
objectively I don't know if Knight D4
was possible to play but I think if B5
is not really bad then it's a logical
choice to play B5 because after that for
sure it's going to be a very complicated
game and there are a lot of things can
happen calculations tactics and after
all one bone is still up for an ish
right while Knight D4 could be very
passive and on the top level you will
find very few people who like to grab
pawns and have a passive position for a
long term
no longer the times of steinerts he was
saying you know it's worth it to suffer
a little bit for a born
yeah that's one of my weaknesses I
notice materialism just uh I see
material I tend to at least allow myself
to suffer uh in return for it yeah but
also if let's say this would be move 22
position and it would be 99
that none of the players are in the
books and home prep then of course it's
another story right but when you're
hesitating whether I mean really you
want to take that pawn no I would have
been terrified to take that pawn because
the queen gets kicked around a bit but
uh the position is going to explode open
because white has to prove that they
they have some play for this pawn and so
I was kind of looking at like moves like
Rook D1 or do you just go D5 immediately
should we jump in and see what Magnus is
going to do let's try and get inside his
head now Anish has not taken up the
challenge of grabbing a second pawn and
okay I was gonna try and get inside his
head he answers the question for US
route to D1 first uh they do say threat
stronger than the execution so now D5 is
potentially a threat and it's really
uncomfortable for the black queen to be
stared down by the white Rook well I
think it's the most obvious move because
if you would play Bishop E3 then it
wouldn't make any sense to play Queen E2
first I believe and anyway you want to
keep the bishop for a moment on C1
and of course D5 is something that black
will have to look after
this is the the big question D5 and E5
both yes are in every move you have to
calculate and count on that that
actually I like more E5 and after Knight
D5 Knight E4 but it would have been
probably too early so white wants to
keep the option
uh how to continue and also after Knight
D5 by the way sometimes can't Knight D5
be the move if Queen D5 is not possible
yeah if you can force black to take with
the pawn then yes black has a queen Side
Pawn mask Queen side poor majority but
white has great attacking chances right
Judith uh Bishop F4 can come sometimes
even E6 can come and yeah white has the
advantage on the king side that's where
the action might happen but it seems to
me that the position is very complicated
if we go back to the position after Rook
B1 Bishop B7 is very logical also Knight
B4 sometimes you just go there in Knight
D3
it really bothers white uh cam yeah so
let's say Bishop B7 and Magnus tries the
other Pawn D5 to try and hit immediately
before anything dramatic happens the
idea he takes D5 E5 right yeah this must
be the idea I think take it with the
pawn just to show the audience the night
before
firstly this Pawn might just drop off
the board secondly this Knight's coming
into D3 blocking kind of plugging
everything here and it's only black
having all the fun unless white has
something uh any immediate tactics that
we don't really see so the whole idea
must be after each hd5 E5 but you know
what maybe I would sacrifice the night
there every night before anyway
the cool idea giving up the night but uh
look at all these pawns if they start
rolling C5 D4 D3
they'll be far superior to a piece I
love that movie voice you put on there
David yes
uh yeah Bishop takes F6 this looks great
to me the evaluation bar uh let's
probably Bishop B3
stopping and controlling the black
squares that can be annoying for black
and after Knight D3 probably Knight E1
maybe an argument as well for capturing
sometimes indeed but Knight T1 yeah just
get rid of this beast on D3 and white
does have the extra piece so really
complicated if white didn't give up the
piece uh sorry if black didn't cover the
piece here with Knight to B4 as you
mentioned Andrew that going back feels a
bit counter-intuitive at least now it
looks like White's having all the fun
six maybe in the uh well this is too
nice to be true yeah
but this is what Anish has to calculate
and uh yeah D5 looks like the one that
Magnus is going to go for in the current
position if he's allowed and a niche
needs to get ready brace himself for
impact because it's coming and look at
this jacket off from Anish he means
business he knows that this is a
critical moment in the game
oh this one is brewing up really nicely
so we will keep a close eye on this one
shall we go to the bird's eye view and
take a look at some of the other
encounters and the one of course I'm
dying to revisit is the game between
Fabiana caruana and Shaq mamajarov
because that one
was I didn't know what was happening to
be honest it felt like either it was
fantastic for Carolina oh yeah Shaq has
uh got his preparation in and it's it's
okay
for black
yeah the one thing we can say about this
game is Shaq is not on the attack he's
very much on the defensive right now and
it's just about whether Fabby first of
all uh is he is still in preparation
does he know what's going on is his
attack dangerous enough we see Fabiano
away from the board right now the game
has progressed two or three moves since
we were last here
and uh White's last move just like in
the Magnus game was ripped to D1
and yeah there's still a pawn of Life on
E6 that makes me scared for black the
black king really open if white gets
time maybe we'll see H4 H5 trying to use
that H Pawn as a battering ram to open
up lines against the black king
I would be terrified to steal this black
but one or two moves if the Queens ever
disappear safety it's a very challenging
position for black I believe because if
we see that how harmonious and active
piece is white have right and this is
what the Fabiano does in this tournament
if I look it back on his games he he has
a very healthy way of playing you will
not really find any of his pieces being
somewhere in the storage in the position
you know somehow you will see that all
the pieces are playing and they have its
role I mean you can hardly imagine a
more active position as it is right now
with the bishop pair and there is a huge
question for black how can he get out of
this very difficult position F5 is never
possible practically because Bitcoin E5
goes back Rook cannot take on E6 because
from Bishop and E4 goes Bishop D5 and
bends The Rook if black plays C6 to stop
Bishop D5 then The Rook on A6 is cut out
completely the queen from E7 usually
in such a position is not something you
want to move away because then suddenly
white can maybe just sacrifice on the E7
so black has to incredibly accurate in
order to to make his moves
there's uh no doubt about it black is
living on the edge and it just feels
like one mistake and he could be in
serious trouble
yeah one such mistake might be getting
really going porn grabbing suddenly you
mentioned at this point you alerted me
to it you didn't don't take on A3 I
think uh like you said there will be a
release of the blockade The Black Queen
will be forced away in the white Pawn
will just simply run through and I'm
just noticing one more thing that after
Rook 8d1 you know Bishop B7 might be an
attacking idea after Bishop D7 to
control with the Rook the seventh round
going Rook D7 and capturing on C7
afterwards so that can be a deadly
threat right now wow wow that's a nice
idea right I think we have to jump in
and uh show this and look at mamajara's
body language he does not look happy at
all looks like he's suffering he would
love to have the white side of this
position you've got to say uh suits his
style and just Judah to show your your
point there Pawn to A4 or just any
waiting move might just allow Bishop
takes B7 and The Rook coming in and
suddenly it's chaotic but it looks like
his favors white with the Rook getting
to the side seventh rank only one safe
Square for the queen and I mean can we
go for checkmate do we just take this
Pawn as he's pointed out Bishop F6 is
not bad at all but also Queen C7 was
something that I was considering yeah
somehow the winter
yes something on the seventh rank
there's gonna be a Checkmate here and
blacks Bishops are both dropping so
maybe a Thrust on the board uh in the
current position with Bishop takes B7 so
somehow I have the feeling that black
can make and find the right move by
eliminating all the rest
yeah you can't play a slow waiting move
you cannot uh capture this Pawn as you
mentioned just because well I assume you
can't because of some pins along the
this e-file I don't see a knockout blue
for white but
must be something somewhere you would
think well it is something that actually
a black should
check it right but what about taking on
B7 first and only after that when The
Rook moves coming back to D5 yep level
material a pin along this diagonal pin
along this line
scary stuff maybe black is okay the
evaluation bar hints that black has a
defense but well probably King G7 or
King King h8 but yeah okay maybe King h8
just so there are no checks on C7 but
yes at the very least I can start
thinking about taking and cashing in on
this Pawn at the end
oh hang on a second because the
evaluation bar just shut up I thought
you can just simply exchange everything
on E6 and go Queen C7
we need two maybe we need two Rook F1
so just to show this queen takes C7
winning a pawn queen comes to E2
and rooked F1 defending
yeah what's going to be a pawn up
yeah I think we have to start with the
Rook exchange on E6 because after Bishop
E6 Rook B2 would have been ah yes of
course counter starting with Rook takes
E6 and it leads to the exact same
variation
so as you said process of elimination if
this doesn't look promising for black
then you rule this one out
you can't pass like you said you did
Rook take C6 this is just a pin and a
win for white maybe D6
to try and trade off pieces and to try
and stop your idea of getting the Rook
into the seventh rank
after Rook D6 I thought maybe Rook D5
can uh can I go to D5 or just go B6
is on the right track
also now that you've occupied the D5
Square maybe I can take here now this
time Bishop B6 oh Bishop E6 Rook E6
kind of taken away the D5 Square from
your own Bishop there so so let's see
Rook D6 makes a lot of sense
so what we're taking on these six okay I
will take back with the bishop
and now I have to move something really
good
if I can Quinn now
Queen F3 Queen
one of these one of these quests Maybe
on Queen F3 I thought black just played
C6 covering the D5
and threatens to take on E6
Yeah the more pieces come off the board
the more this Pawn looks like a weakness
than a strength and okay black would
eliminate a very active Rook right so
the exchange of Rooks it definitely
helps black to be able to defend
yeah so far this looks like the most
promising to me in the game position
like you said process of elimination I
don't see anything other than Rook D6 to
be honest
and you can't do anything fancy if the
root comes to D6 like I was one a common
idea so like lengthen the diagonals
and I was looking at ways of doing them
you know radical stuff with G4 G5 but
that's obviously going to take time
yeah actually 4g5 to lengthen this
diagonal and there's maybe H4 H5 at some
point to length B5
uh-huh I can imagine what my plan is so
cheap F6 stuff yeah I I would ask her
the question C6 I think I can go Bishop
F6 right okay Bishop takes F6
maybe just Pawn takes
let's say I just take this I've taken
queen of Fate yeah so simple I'm still
scared but looks like everything holds
black has two Bishops for a rook in this
final position material advantage so
after Rook D6
yeah maybe shark's okay
but uh he's in the tank now he spent
about 11 minutes so I think it's uh kind
of a good practical use of time here a
good investment if you find throughout
D6 or similar move to keep the game
and he knows it it's a crucial period of
a game because I can't say that it's a
crucial moment exactly but this moment
is something where you have to spend the
time he went down to 121 he spent 40
minutes almost similarly Fabiano also
spent so far 35 minutes
it's uh what is uh nearly move 20 but
you know that if you make one move
it can be over if you make the precise
moves maybe you're getting away with
this awfully dangerous position and uh I
think the jury's out still here on this
position so shall we go back to the
bird's eye view and have a look at some
of the other games and one game
I am very curious about
and that is the game between our fourth
commentator Hikaru Nakamura our man on
site against the birthday boy Ariana who
celebrated his 24th birthday today
now the reason why I kind of wanted to
pull up this position is because
Hikaru has put his Knight on the edge of
the board and there's always like
possibilities one that happens
well I think it's it's very clear
Nakamura said it also that well
basically tari is not doing so well so
far in the tournament and he's the
underdog in this tournament so obviously
he wants to win the game and I'm pretty
sure that he wants to win the game first
in the classical game he knows that he
has to catch up or try to catch up to
Fabiano they are on the lead right they
are in the top two seed so he knows that
this is his chance he has to try
whatever it takes and Knight H4 is the
kind of move that okay I'm ready to
fight I'm ready to pull out my sword and
shortly I show my intentions to be
jumping on your neck Knight F5 King H1
F4 so to be kind of aggressive in this
position right and how aggressive can
Hikaru be it sounds like like how low
can you go how aggressive can you go
um okay
let's uh
Knight F5 King H1
Bishop G5 I think it's also very
important to pose problems to your
opponent and this is also the case by
playing Knight H4 that now white is
asking black do you allow me to go
Knight F5 or you play G6 and you make
weaknesses and allow me to play Bishop
H6 if you move your knight you go to C5
and E6 or you're going to make Knight B6
to open up your Bishop but then you
block your other Bishop so there are a
lot of questions to be answered in this
position for black and you can easily
spend your time on this move and then
the next move so this is one of the most
important technique and tactics for
strong players playing against weaker
that maybe you you cannot win just like
that but you have to pose problems and
you have to force your opponent for
making decisions right and if you do
make a move like King H1 we also have to
consider that Ariane 2 has some
opportunities the Knight on H4 is loose
our movies like Knight takes Pawn on e4
are they in the air
I certainly have to be calculated uh
let's maybe jump in we've mentioned a
few ideas here for white and let's try
and figure out which one Hikaru is going
to go for so you just mentioned King H1
there Ivanka I'm not so sure about
Knight takes E4 because white can simply
recapture and Bishop G5 I think traps
the queen on H4
um so this yeah this is rice I actually
fell for this exact trick when I was
young two or three times I was like oh
they put their Knight in H5 it was like
with colors reversed and I went to grab
it and got trapped uh so bad flashbacks
there but uh King H1 yeah maybe
something to do with this Knight and
often just I'm playing by analogy here
with colors reversed uh here white is
playing the Italian game uh sorry black
is playing the Italian game just with
colors uh switched and often you don't
have to worry about F4 that much you can
kind of just ignore I'm worried I'm
wondering about maybe Knight C5 as you
mentioned there Judith now F4 maybe
Knight takes E4 is an issue because this
Knights might be threatened for example
F4 I'm wondering
now you can get away with it
maybe makes D takes e Queen H4
yeah it seems like quite okay for black
probably Queen F3
queen of three black is one upon though
uh it feels like black should be safe
enough maybe bishop E6 just to uh kind
of kill your uh scary uh kind of potent
Bishop here on A2 yeah
yeah um so yeah after Knight C5 if F4
isn't possible then it does beg the
question is King H1 the best use of a
Tempo and maybe you want to use that
Tempo in other ways the other move that
the two of you mentioned and also very
attractive very natural Knight F5
uh it hits this Pawn gets nearer to the
king Ariane is surely going to move his
Knight out the way
at least hinting that he might capture
this piece
Queen F3 was blade okay oh queen of
three in that position uh also possible
but same idea from Hikaru Queen to F3
and
okay he's just keeping this one up his
sleeve up his pocket for later yeah like
like still asking uh Atari right like
I sure you don't want to play G6 and
stop my knight to go to F5 and
also of course after Queen F3 if let's
say the D7 Knight is moving away Bishop
G5 can be unpleasant to pin the F6
Knight
mm-hmm it's much much more flexible I
think that's a great idea uh in general
in chess against lower rated players
kind of keeping them guessing it's a
nice Motif and Hikaru gets away from the
board that gets my hopes up every time
that he's coming to update us on his
thoughts I think this can be a time when
he shares his uh feelings about his
position and the other games because
this is a moment already where he knows
more or less where he's going right he
knows his plans it is very clear that he
wants to be very active and go straight
forward out
uh it's really a question whether what
about Knight C5 because somehow that
seems to be the most logical to me to
open up the diagonal for the bishop and
play Bishop E6 to eliminate the y-square
bishop for white
indeed sadly it looks like a good
antidote there for our antari and it's
time for a quick break but don't go too
far because we will be back in a few
minutes with all the thrilling action
thank you
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the Champions chess tour to
the candidates speed chess championship
title Tuesday feed a world championship
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
and review games from the world's
greatest players with live commentary
cloud analysis opening Explorer and
table bases find all the key event
information including schedules prizes
results news reports player bios tie
breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
is uh is anybody in snoops Camp playing
chess is that happening or not I haven't
seen it there's some smart people in the
camp so I wouldn't be surprised if
people
are versed at it
a lot of college educated people you
know I unfortunately am not one of those
sophisticated people that play chess in
the camp she talking about man I don't
play chess
I mean you know how to play I listen
there's a difference with knowing how to
start a car up and then driving Formula
One racing
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Norway land of fjords Majestic mountains
Cliffs and waterfalls
in addition to stunning geography Norway
is home to the greatest chess player who
has ever lived Magnus Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best
from Carlson's fiercest online rival
today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps laude Beck Abdul
sotorov and kukesh domaraju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023 Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana
two more long-time Headliners seek to
take their next turn Atop A major
tournament Wesley so and shakriya mamac
yarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
Arian tari rounds out the field who will
come out on top will Carlson run the
table yet again or will someone else
usurp the throne this is Norway chess
welcome back everyone and we've had an
exciting start to round five of Norway
chess and for those of you who just
joined us I'm your host International
master ivankajka and it's been great fun
calling all the action alongside grandma
says Judith Polgar and David Howe and
whoa could you have expected that the
pace has heated heated up so much
or oh it's it's quite uh getting into it
I must say of course we have two
incredible interesting game already
Fabiano's game against shock and also
Magnus vs Anish but on the other boards
also slowly but it starts to boil yeah
and uh for you David
yeah have you expected the players have
come out with uh interesting opening
ideas some Novelties this desire to win
I think if you'd asked me before the
tournament I would have been impressed
but at this point it's becoming normal
it feels like every round they're trying
uh anything just to beat each other and
uh yeah here we have five really tense
games some more exciting than others of
course but all of them have the
potential to really heat up and we see
on the camera there the clash between
Wesley so and alireza farouza farouza
has been burning a lot of time on the
clock you can see from his body language
he's clearly worried about his position
and I think we have to go there for an
update it hasn't fizzled out to an early
theoretical draw that was I think the
main fear and also I do have bad
memories about this exact position uh so
maybe I'll share some of those with the
audience uh here we see that the game
has progressed White's active Rook on
the seventh rank has disappeared we see
a trade white does have the Bishops
though white has this very strong Pawn
on D5 it's always a debate the grinfeld
whether this point is a strength or
whether Black's a pawn is more important
but right now black is behind in the
race and also this Pawn attacked and uh
yeah I remember when I was about 12
years old I had I think this exact
position and it was in a correspondence
game with a teacher at a school that I
was going to go to and uh he played
chess I think he was about 1600 1700
level and he was like okay let's play
correspondence game by mail and uh he's
like no cheating though no books no
computers
and of course he crushed me and years
later I looked every move of his was the
top computer choice
so a bit naughty there uh shout out to
that teacher you know who you are
and I just remember in that game I uh
yeah I very quickly started running the
a pawn and I got punished white uh after
I think I played King f8 in that game
white played Bishop E2 and he just
rolled forward with F4 E5 very quickly
and
I was uh yeah rolled off the board well
indeed this is the big question in this
system that black has great pieces right
Knight on E5 stands outstanding there
but white wants to go back first of all
the G5 Bishop is putting a lot of
pressure attacking the E7 bone so the
question is whether you play Queen A3 or
rookie 8 or possibly King f8 and then
white wants to go Bishop going back to
E2 and then really the storm starts with
F4 and E5 so this is the big big
question whether can black stop this and
the for this reason actually the queen
on A2 stands pretty well because many
times the Knight comes to C4 so after F4
the E3 Square gets weak and of course it
is the big question whether the a pawn
will ever be a great postpone or it's
going to be a weak one
yeah it's uh interesting dilemma here as
well because the first thing that jumps
to my mind here is I wasn't necessarily
thinking of immediately defending the E7
Pawn I was thinking of trading that uh
night for the bishop now I know
optically that Knight looks great on E5
after all it's a fantastic blockader but
at the same time you feel like the more
pieces that get traded the closer you
are to that draw but is this like a
common Pitfall for black well uh you're
right Ivanka often it's maybe too
tempting to capture a bishop like this
one but it might just come down to
concrete uh variations here if you could
maintain this Knight only five you'll be
loving life the night is a great
blockade as you say it's got tentacles
all over the board but unfortunately
it's about to get hit within the next
two moves if white gets time to retreat
so yeah taking on this uh Square the
problem is it might just improve and
accelerate whites play after the White
Queen recaptures on F3 you still have
the same dilemma how to protect this
pawn and White's Rook is then ready to
slide across White's Queen very active
um yeah I'm trying to recall what my uh
opening notes say what my opening
analysis says sometimes you can get away
with a move like Bishop F6 but again
that one kind of
it's very risky you allow your Pawn
structure to be compromised there and
it's all about the bishop pair so right
now it's definitely a difficult position
and okay they're in the feature chat we
do see that uh one of our viewers is
saying Bishop F6 is the only move to
maintain equality in this position
um yeah it just it rings the bell Bishop
F6 but yeah very committal maybe not
obvious to someone like ferrugia who
doesn't employ the grinfeld on such a
regular basis yeah I just checked and
there's engine's Top Choice second
choice is Queen A3 definitely don't get
tempted to trade the bishop the Knight
for the bishop
well of course Bishop F6 seems to be a
very concrete move and actually posing
quite immediate question whether to
should he exchange on F6 and after ef6
can he go back Bishop E2 and quickly
play F4 to push away denied but one
thing is for sure black has to play it
very active because when Black Goes
passive play night let's say after F4
goes back to D7 that gives all the
opportunity for white to to conquer in
the game but black should be trying to
go to C4 and it's very typical that the
queen stands on A2 and puts pressure on
the on the bishop on E2 so white cannot
go Queen D4 or can't come out so uh
actively immediately because he has to
watch after his Bishop to defend it and
of course when you start playing A5 and
then already crossing the half board and
you push A4 then suddenly white really
has to be careful on about that postpone
and it is
sometimes it happens that you just
simply simplify the position you end up
in a rook end game where you have a good
pass spawn white has of course a very
nice center with E4 and D5 Pawn but or
even postpone uh but it can be not
enough in many cases
and meanwhile we see that version didn't
ask that question he didn't pose a
question to that Bishop instead
retreating with Queens A3 also a logical
move also approved by uh the computers
we mentioned and now there's a question
is this a threat if so does white simply
Retreat you know it's also interesting
that with the bishop on G7 somehow you
don't want to give up because once the a
pawn reaches to A4 A3 then most of the
time there is no way that white can stop
that past spawn so black needs one or
two moves and this will be the question
whether will he get there so if let's
say Bishop moves back to E2
and prepares the move F4 then for
example black can maybe play A5 F4
but F4 is also tricky because the queen
on A3 so you can give it check on E3
forcing the king to move yeah it's a
question if you can uh yeah I was
thinking that fe5 is not the thread but
Bishop takes E7 is
right but you can play some like Snappy
defensive moves like for instance Knight
C6 unless
but uh why it's a nice one
my words because there is a strong Pawn
on C6 but and the Knight on C6 is loose
yeah you mean the text C6 is possible
you never know maybe they take C6 takes
and Rook D1 exactly learning from gokash
from yesterday just to show this on the
board Queen takes now there would be a
check and
Checkmate along uh this back rank
Black's Bishop caught in the crossfire
here white white king will be safe on H2
beautiful tactics Ivanka uh could we see
a variation like that either way if we
go back to the current position I think
Bishop E2 is pretty much guaranteed just
there's nothing else really productive
to do there's too much attention Knight
takes Bishop is too big of a threat in
some variations ties down the White
Queen so I think the bishop will simply
drop back and the question will pass
back to farusha actually there is a
question for me after Bishop B2 you know
H6 makes some sense to ask the bishop
where is going to go back because if you
go to F4 then you don't have the move F4
right if you go back to E3 then the F4
is not threatening temporary because of
the A3 Queen putting pressure on the E3
a bishop so maybe H6 after Bishop E2
yeah let's jump back in uh on the board
here after Queen to A3 Bishop E2 looks
like it's nailed on at this point feels
like Wesley's guaranteed almost to play
that move after a short think H6 your
suggestion here Judith I do Wonder
firstly like you say Bishop H4 I wonder
about this one as well it looks a bit
odd just to gain a bit of time against
your queen
ah you want to push me back if I want to
I'm just desperate to play F4 okay so
Queen B4 or queen C3 Queen C3 is also a
great spot but Queen B4 is also pretty
good because attacking the E4 Pawn yeah
I like your queen B4 somehow
instinctively I think win B4 yeah
because tempies are extremely important
right now
if I do get courageous and start pushing
your knight back
Knight C
six maybe but Knight C4 was my original
plan aha juvanka's idea is contagious
Knight C6 yeah Knight C4 as well and
it's really tense again white always
wants to step forward but it's hard to
achieve this kind of if you look out
this black Bishop but at the same time a
move like this one means that this Pawn
in the center will fall so this is
double edged and yeah black is so active
right now it could certainly go either
way this type of position
uh so that's what I think Wesley's
calculating right now uh Bishop E2 I
don't really understand why he's
thinking
don't see another logical move to be
honest uh you need to firstly activate
your queen you need to get the queen uh
kind of active and yeah F4 is the bigger
of the two deals here but it can be the
case that the reason he is not making
this most obvious move because
he wants the opponent to spend the time
and once he plays Bishop E2 he wants to
be ready to make and Flash it out his
next move whether it's going to be H6
and where he puts his bishop or A5 so
maybe he wants to get ready and I play
Bishop E2 and once H6 I'm just flushing
out Bishop C1 and then also I know my
next move because it's not nice if he's
making after a few minutes plays Bishop
E2 then black plays the move then again
he thinks another 15 minutes right so
somehow he wants to be preparing himself
and he has plenty of time because he
spent only 40 minutes up to now and he
has much more time still than Fairuza he
was spending nearly one hour already up
to this point yeah this is where I'd be
sneaky though I see my opponents left
the board they've gone away from the
board I'd quickly make the move press
the clock and hope they lose two or
three minutes
well uh I can I guess he could be
thinking for Russia's time there but
yeah I have no doubt eventually he'll
play B2 and white spawn Center
whites Bishop against the potential of
the activity and energy of flex pieces
that's the current status quo well let's
see what is going to be up to and switch
to which game to switch what do you
think
let's
definitely go to Magnus
because it looks incredibly intense and
each Gary still a pawn up but uh is
having to play with a very passive
position
yeah so this game between Magnus uh
Carlson and Anish giri is developed by
two moves since we were last here but
two very important moves we see that
white still has the option of some
Central breaks but the question is is
this the moment Black's last move rookie
I really like it I've got to say rook's
opposite Queens are often a great
deterrent to the position opening up and
now with uh White Queen is stuck on E2
it's really
well it feels unlikely that D5 will be a
viable option at least on this turn
so what do we think here so you can
break through in the center but I've
also seen people play um no namely
against me is put the Knight on E5
and their whole concept is okay well you
know get a good piece afterwards it's
somewhat unpleasant for black to
actually capture that Knight in the
center
it was for now after Knight E5 I think
black can capture on the E4 with the
tempo and after that stabilized the
Knight with C5 I forgot about that basic
point
so for now it's uh black is still safe
completely against Knight E5 and it's
interesting that I always like to say
that when you play an opening or you
study an opening you have to understand
what is the spirit of the position and
in this kind of position you know it by
heart that various pieces are more or
less standing right with white it's very
typical you will find hundreds of games
like this where white has the Queen on
E2 Rook on D1 the two Pawns in the
center bishopon F4 you have H4 and then
you start well maybe sometimes Bishop H3
sometimes D5 or E5
A4 very rarely in such a position
because after B4 and with black it's
also something very common to have the
pawn chain of a6b5c4 protecting each
other Bishop has to be standing on B7
right the Knight on C6 many times it's
there attacking the D4 and going Knight
B4 Knight D3 options
Andrew Coney 8 is also something that is
very common because it's a
prophylactical move to play against
possible D5 so the next move probably
black would be playing Bishop f8 to put
even more prophylactical uh ideas behind
rookie 8.
yeah so what could be a useful move here
for Magnus you mentioned a bunch of
plans but it doesn't look like there's
anything too direct what order would
will he improve his pieces in how will
he kind of prepare to eventually break
open the center I have an immediate
question
I wanted to go somehow Queen E3 and to
put in in the threat Knight E5 or Bishop
H6 potentially so the idea is to defend
the pawn on the E4
and you mentioned maybe it's not good is
that because after Queen to E3 black can
I guess play Knight G4 but then I would
come back Retreat to E1 or D2 probably
to D2
I like that idea
can I suggest yeah one of mine is a bit
radical let's jump in and try to study
some of these ideas Ivanka you mentioned
another idea in this position yeah I
mean black is very cramped I mean
because their pieces are Tangled on the
queen side so I thought you know do
something which is a bit anti-cataland
but actually move the bishop to H3
in order to get some free hand over
there on the queen on the king side
because I also want to go but although I
can see the bar ahead said this is not
to be done so obviously
well I don't know if let's follow
through with the idea let's say black
plays a move that true Dimension Bishop
f8
what was uh the follow-up was it to push
pause was it to explode open G4 G5
eventually
[Laughter]
um yeah I mean I wanted to go Queen E3
and also G4 and uh just enjoy that extra
space that white has on the king side
and and I can see but one thing I I can
see that the bar is like absolutely I
think Knight B4 can be strong at this
point okay so maybe
maybe you can kind of wait with this
kind of idea and just make a proprietary
move instead of Bishop H3 so maybe you
can just go A3 I mean is that a good
move to kind of take away this other
possibility of black playing Knight B4
yeah it crosses my mind A3 as well just
to prevent night before forever so D5
might come with more power but you've
also weakened the B3 Square so there
might be some World in which black plays
a move like Knight to A5 maybe jumps
into B3
it's uh it's hard to call here I mean
it's going to become very concrete as
well and while Magnus does commit maybe
he sensed that this was the moment now
or never and E5 on the board
so something you mentioned earlier
Judith attacking this Knight and it's
really committal because it does give
away this beautiful Outpost in the
center D5 probably it means that after
Knight D5 he wants to take it it must
mean that right though I'm not sure
because after Knight D5 takes Queen D5 I
was thinking at first to go Knight H2
but that would be a mistake to Queen G2
and Knight D4 jackets boom ouch discover
check wins the game
yeah you only merge up with two extra
pawns because I thought naively that I
go Knight H2 then I come D5 Knight G4
and then the attack is there on the
king's side but it's uh it's not an
option
could it be Knight to E1 then just to
cover the square so the white king will
never get glued forward and when the
black queen moves then D5 Maybe
well that's definitely something to
consider I believe maybe D5 okay
evaluation bar is mocking our moves here
uh maybe we start this actually with
something you mentioned earlier
something like Queen G4
um just on the board just to pin and try
to win threats
Bishop takes H6 here and also the pin
not only on the G5 but also the the pin
on the E6 spawn right so D5 will be much
stronger yeah maybe this is magnus's
idea uh Knight takes D5 and just to
point out if the pawn takes then it's
something we alluded to earlier now the
queen side is basically completely
closed the center completely closed and
yes white is a pawn down but white
complete on the king size maybe with a
move like E6 in this position or maybe a
slower build up like Queen E3 as you
were mentioning and uh Knight H2 Knight
G4 or I'm not sure maybe maybe
white wants to go after Knight D5 to go
back to D2 can you imagine that and if
there is a possibility in Knight D4 and
if black takes on C3 then bc3 with a
better phone structure than before
possibly although from my experience the
move I mean if you can get one more move
here like Knight E7 put it on D5 like
would be safe
and uh yeah it's uh up to anishagiri now
will he go into all these forcing lines
that we've been mentioning that's the
big question and uh well we have a very
unique Insight from another man that we
have on site uh Magnus Carlson actually
went to the confessional spoke in
Norwegian and told us that he's trying
two plans plan one was changing his
looks didn't work so the other plan is
to sacrifice a pawn as soon as possible
which would bring him success in his
best times and then his whole plan is
play in the center let's see if that one
works
what do you guys think change looks I
always like that that's the that's the
plan a and then plan B
freestyle in the center
well you know that the chess players
were much more I think but even nowadays
they are superstitious so obviously you
had your winning pen and you had your
winning sweater that's what I had for
with my first big International success
it was my winning sweater so I had to
have it every game it was four day event
and uh of course when things are not
going on your way you try to look for
some small details and change your habit
your routine your uh whatever and of
course Magnus understands that he's kind
of rusty in this tournament so far so he
really wants to go and and win a good
game okay am I going to put you both on
the spot have you ever done the Magnus
approach of changing your looks
and then just kind of going you know
what I don't care anymore I'm just
simply going to play chess and whatever
happens will happen
I didn't change my look but it happened
that things didn't go on my way I said
okay I'm not going to be preparing today
just something very little and then I go
for a walk I want to be in the right
mindset that was much more important
than a preparation yeah yeah and I've
never sacrificed my beard because I
can't I can't grow a bit unfortunately
so I've never done the Magnus Gambit in
that regard but uh yeah I have often
tried to shift things up sometimes you
know turn up in new clothes or you know
change up the routine completely have a
lion or wake up early I go for a run
that type of thing but uh either way I
think change of routine is key when
results aren't going your way and
meanwhile we have a couple of moves uh
dramatic times on the board he's still a
pawn down that sacrifice has been
long-term Magnus Carson but will he be
repaid that's uh another question it's
hard against the top players in the
world even if you're Magnus to kind of
win on demand to switch things up and
kind of go on that winning streak but
you predicted it true that Knight D5
answered by a capture and now a niche
calculation mode we saw head in hands
just briefly there
and I think also when we talk about
Magnus I mean he's still number one in
the world he gave up he made a very
strange unexpected decision just after
the candidates tournament saying that
okay I give up my title I'm not going to
be fighting for my thought title and I
think that mindset uh must have been in
one hand very difficult to make the
decision but he he if he wanted to
change things in his life and and I
think now he's in a period where he's
kind of doesn't feel so comfortable with
the chess board somehow things are not
going on his way maybe the preparation
the opponents are not playing the lines
he would be the most comfortable with
and so he's he's somehow looking for
himself how to give and pose the biggest
problems and challenges for the opponent
and uh do you think like somehow like
giving up the title that maybe he's a
bit more relaxed with his preparation
maybe more relaxed with like having the
pressure to play tournaments
maybe we'll relax but again for chess
it's not clear whether that's a good
thing sometimes you need a certain level
of intensity uh you need to be focused
unfortunately chances of also you need
to do a lot of work in classical chess
just to get a fight and
um yeah Magnus he seems like he's in a
good place I don't think he misses the
world title too much but at the same
time chess results there are some
questions I think unfortunately he's
achieved everything there is to achieve
so there's going to be questions when he
doesn't win
and uh meanwhile we do see Knight takes
D5 on the board Judo this is the reason
that okay he achieved everything and
more than that right uh but at the same
time it's very difficult once you
achieved so much in the Chess World and
you're the number one highest rated
player it is very difficult I think to
look for uh motivation and why how and
it's okay he wants to play he wants to
win but in deep down he has to explain
it to himself that really what is my
motivation to play to win another game
to win another tournament to be number
one for another five years is it really
going to make a difference in my life so
what is that that it makes makes it
special to win a tournament or to play a
good game I think that's what he's he's
very eager also to Simply to play well
to make some very very tasty Victory
right that would please him but do you
think that he's getting as much Joy now
from Chas as he perhaps used to because
I mean let's face it he's been playing
chess since he was a kid
uh I can ask the question back at us
here in the studio do we enjoy it as
much as we were kids because I guess
with age you see more you learn more you
understand more but
yeah that thrill of kind of not knowing
anything that can be refreshing as well
well to enjoy chess I think that's not a
question in my case that I enjoy chess
very much even though I retired from
competitive chess I can find this beauty
I'm enjoying it a lot the commentating
here and watching the games and for me
it doesn't it's not a problem they make
mistakes or whatever
so the game I think it's something that
that a professional player enjoys in
different forms but when you have the
competition aspect then you have to
analyze again and again and over again
the same lines and you're kind of stuck
and you're frustrated with that that can
take away your enjoyment playing in a
tournament for example I can't imagine
Magnus not enjoying some chess
brilliances I can't imagine Gary who
retired already nearly 20 years ago I
mean I know how how eager he can be with
the chest study puzzles or something
some brilliancy idea so chess itself is
really engaging I think in my case
definitely right but maybe not in the
context of a competition so to speak and
have you ever had like an existential
crisis where you just thought I don't
want to do chats anymore but what am I
good at
no backup plan that's the problem chess
players we tend to be good at one thing
and that's chess
um I normally have that one that kind of
crisis of confidence when results aren't
going my way often I'm like wait was I
ever good at chess like how do I how did
I win games in the past I can't win at
the moment but
I don't know like you said the love is
still there so I keep coming back how
about you two
well it's uh I mean of course you have
points in your career I had also
somewhere in the year 2000 I I want some
events but I also in the beginning of
the year from 99 to 2000 for example I
had some crisis when simply you feel
nothing works on your way the opening
preparation you have a winning position
you don't win you just simply don't get
good positions so there are different
levels of uh of getting disappointed
with yourself and and these moments it's
very hard to recover but I think the
most important thing is to to calm down
and in a slow space you recover with
your self-confidence playing in the in
with players who are lower level somehow
gaining games being surrounded with
players who believe in you who support
you to get new ideas maybe to start
working with the new training Partners
but you definitely they have to change
but I think generally this is one of the
most difficult thing in in life and in a
sport career also how can you recharge
and how can you restart if you have to
or make dramatic changes in order to
develop further yeah and uh I just ask
you I mean how did you recover from that
tough patch because you mentioned you
made some changes in the chess playing
side of it but on a personal level I
mean did you do anything did you
for instance take up sports did you push
yourself in other ways yeah that was
always important for me to be consistent
on that and to do some Sport and maybe
to to learn something more or switch to
other sport but the
patience is also something extremely
important to have not only at the chess
board but sometimes with yourself
I like that patience I hear you patient
David uh at the chess board yes in life
less so
I get impatient for things all the time
if someone hasn't replied to my email
immediately I'm like what are you doing
but at the chessboard yeah uh patience
is key and yeah I think the patience is
linked to belief it's like belief that
things will turn out well in the end you
will get that result you will improve
you will find that love again of the
game yeah it's something that whether
you're convinced that you're on the
right path right then patience and time
works on on your end but now in the
position of the Knight D5 it seems like
Anish is very uncertain how to decide to
capture it with the queen or with the
pawn and this I can say that it's a very
important moment of the game
yeah it's two completely different
decisions right if he takes with the
queen then it's going to get very sharp
very tactical immediately uh basically
white is going to go for the black king
White's gonna explode the center and
either you'll find that and you
calculate your way out or you might be
in big big trouble if you take with a
pawn however you'll be fine you'll
survive the next few moves that's
guaranteed but long term white will have
compensation kind of strategically is
that desirable you look out your your
light squared Bishop there and you might
well get checkmated on the king side
slowly so it's kind of do you want the
Slow Burn approach or do you want the
first kind of fireworks yeah and this is
where I'm going to put you both on the
spot and I'm going to ask you to bet
what do you think Anish will go for
Queen takes Knight
fireworks calculation Ahoy or are we
gonna see the more solid approach
I know what I would do but I don't think
it's what a niche will do okay what
would you do I would take the with the
pawn just because I'm reluctant to
calculate too much at this early stage
and a niche it's only move 14 he's down
at 47 minutes
I would uh kind of be a bit pragmatic
here unless I'm losing immediately I
don't see why I would be I would just
take with the pawn and game goes on uh I
don't think I'll get checkmated
immediately and there will be critical
moments ahead kind of save the time for
later and we can see some people in chat
saying they would take with a queen what
about you Judith I think if he takes
with the pawn he will lose this game
uh-huh
sorry
just by the structure I feel that the
Magnus played Knight H2 Knight F1 or
Knight G4 regrouping it to E3 then he
starts pushing his pawns and he's
pushing pressure putting Pressure Queen
H5 Bishop H6 I don't know
uh I would rather play Queen D5 okay
anyway I have to challenge you though
well you had it here for it first but
okay it is break time we'll be back with
you in just moments but in the meantime
here's our man Hikari Nakamura with his
hot take on today's matches
foreign
welcome back everyone so we are back
here of course it is round number five
at Norway chess now in a previous round
I talked about my game first and
apparently I got cut off yesterday so
for that reason I'm gonna do everything
in a reverse order where I talk about
the other games first before talking
about my game so it's pretty interesting
so far I mean the most the most
interesting game obviously is between
Fabian and Shakira this has this classic
E4 variation in the Four Knights English
I mean I played this quite recently in
the American Cup against Wesley
um it was playing the world championship
course between ding ding and Napo and
this whole line of Bishop C5 is supposed
to be objectively safe for them Bishop
B4 it should be more forcing per se
Fabiano appears is kind of surprise
chakra he's played this rookie one line
now my guess is I think about the
opposition is most likely it's probably
completely fine for black but I suspect
it's one of these situations where you
have to start playing like a complete
complete lunatic or 3500 computer and
probably I mean just thinking about I
was wondering if black should take on E6
with a pawn go Queen E5 King F7 King E8
and just try to play the position and I
mean I think it's fine but the problem
is again from a practical standpoint
it's probably much easier for white to
play since your black can get stuck in
the center but I'm betting that if you
were to like look at the position with
stockfish it's going to say that it's
complete zero is completely fine white
is nothing
um so it feels like Fabian is kind of
gambling onto the shock bar won't be
able to place that sort of style um so
it's going to be quite interesting
magnus's game of course we have the
Cadillac with Knight C3
um this whole this whole H4 E4 and I
mean it's going to be very aggressive
gonna be a wild game very very unlikely
that will be anything quick
um
what else do we have with neuterbeck
versus uh or nodabreck versus gookash
which of course is these this old
shablock G4 and the the semi-slav uh
this whole H3 Ms Asian who I think I
feel like I've seen it but not probably
the last like I don't know not in the
last like 20 years I remember I was an
up-and-coming player in like the early
2000s I actually played this line quite
a bit this whole this whole G4 line in
fact the longest game that I ever played
um was in this G4 this G4 variation I
believe it was a zoo China it was only
like 229 moves and taught us still and
God only knows like 2004 2005 although
in that game I believe she played Bishop
B4 she didn't take the pawn on G4 so
that's actually interesting as well
um and then the other game is the game
between Wesley and um Wesleyan alirez of
course there's this whole classic
grunfeld line this whole Queen A5 Queen
two Rook B1 or B7 etc etc I remember I
think it was 1999 there was this famous
new and Cheshire book that I remember
studying quite quite avidly there was a
game that was played between I believe
it was Alexander holifman and Peter
lecko Maybe I'm Wrong on the players
certainly but I remember there's like
this there's like 30 pages or something
of non-stop analysis whole long long
line in the gruenfold and um I mean I
think nothing has changed objectively
it's still considered to be a draw but
it's pretty much going to be a memory
test for for Ali Reza whether he can
remember the correct lines because
Wesley is basically saying if you play
it correctly you'll draw if you make
even one mistake you're going to be much
worse than not losing so that's also
um interesting probably a big memory
test there for Ali Reza as far as my
game goes sort of playing it by Phil now
the thing is I prepared something I play
this Bishop's opening and I thought I
just play a slow game but one thing I
realized is because
um tari changes move order and just the
the general sequence of moves I've
actually played a lot of games in
similar positions to what I have so for
that reason I'm deciding to change it up
by playing Knight F3 probably in at
least 100 games online I played Queen F3
Knight G2 Etc against many players most
prominently being this guy Nicholas
theodoro creary online I I swear I've
had the position I don't know how many
times um but I think because Troy
watched my streams as well I'm changing
it up and that's why I played Knight F3
here and probably it's going to turn
back into some kind of weird italian-ish
but black is a Pawn on C6 instead of
Knight I don't know if that's better if
that's worse but of course I literally
don't care you just play chess and
considering how tari struggled I'm just
trying to keep all the pieces on the
board and more importantly my my trainer
Chris Littlejohn who's here he actually
signed into this whole Magnus fantasy
thing and I remember him saying before
the game like he was worried because I
think he has I think one of the piece he
has is my is me or something is like the
king side bishop and so when I won
Bishop C4 he's very worried that Target
plays me like Knight c695 take the
bishop right away and it would maybe
cost him a bunch of points in fantasy
but now I think it's much more likely
I'm Gonna Keep the bishop on the board
maybe go C3 Bishop C2 down the road and
so at least for my trainer in terms of
the the whole fantasy pool he's probably
probably doing well but at any rate it's
going to be a very very long very very
slow game ahead of us um in my game but
all the pieces are on the board and
that's definitely gives me probably a
better chance to win the game than if
there were a bunch of Trades already so
I feel pretty decent
well
welcome back and there we were treated
to hikaru's in-depth thoughts and giving
us verdicts on all the players openings
and well he had some great insights he
telling us that uh between Magnus uh
Carlson and
with a niche yes that it was I was
Magnus filling in a wild mood and then
of course it was going to be a memory
test between Wesley so and alireza
farouza and also giving us some insights
into the Dilemma between trainer and
student when uh Hikaru decided to play
this Bishop's opening and Christmas John
saying don't get that Bishop traded off
I thought was quite funny
yeah just I wish my brain worked as fast
as Icarus I've got to admit uh normally
I do kind of take a look at other games
that are going on around but I don't see
things as deeply as he does and uh he's
kind of assessed things correctly we
think through that here in the studio
looks like it's it's quite interesting
to see that he
that Heath he wants to share it with the
audience it I mean his game was kind of
in last in the line right now in this in
this summary I think and the I was not
sure at all how much he's happy about
his position while he was telling that
he was playing hundreds of games on this
with this queen of 392i if I understand
it correctly but I'm not sure he is
completely happy with the position
because black seems to have a quite
reasonable position to be honest
yeah the one person who will be happy
however is Chris Littlejohn Nakamura is
second uh because White's light squared
Bishop has survived and it has no rival
it's likely to survive for most of the
rest of the game however it is a bit
locked in on this diagonal right now
after Black's last move D5 and you said
he's maybe not too happy to read it uh
he has the bishop pair but black does
have beautiful Knights right now black
has the Santa Black's Bishop looking
very good feels like Terry's done
everything right to equalize or maybe
even more for black it's true that white
has the bishop there but for right now
the A2 Bishop is while it's still there
and it can be powerful sometimes right
now black center is extremely powerful
and very active playing D5 in the last
move so the bishop is blocked there
Knight on F6 Pawn on C6 Queen on date
everything supports the D5 Pawn so for
now for a long time it can be standing
right there immediately there is a
threat taking D takes E4 because it the
the bishop is hanging on D2 and the
black's position is extremely active you
can see that both of the knights on E6
and F6 they are just standing extremely
well Dari made this regrouping with the
Knight Knight D7 Knight C5 and then it
ended up on E6 and in some cases maybe
Knight D4 is also a move which can be
played by black
um so yeah I kind of feel like in light
of all this white actually needs to
clarify the center and so I move that
kind of jump to me was to go Bishop C3
provoke something to come forward and
then step back and then you can get on
with your ideas oh I would love it with
white if you can force black to play D4
but I would think that it's not so easy
to to force that for example after
Bishop E3 what about D takes E4 and
after d takes E4 to go Knight D4 if we
jump into some concrete lines yeah very
good question uh and I think this is
instructive just to show before D takes
E4 juvanka's point if Black Blocks the
center white happily accepts the two
Tempe loss here but suddenly this bishop
is the most valuable piece on the board
A2 Bishop is powerful yeah that was and
the black Bishop on A7 is absolutely uh
well it's stuck there right because the
D4 Pawn is completely blocking its power
yeah and white has Easy Pawn breaks like
F4 to come so D4 I think would be a huge
strategic mistake as you both mentioned
that D takes E4 let's assume white
recaptures are now Knight for this is
the line you're mentioning Judith yeah
this is what I had in mind because now
the E4 point can be vulnerable if you're
grabbing on D4
yeah for example if we take in either
direction actually then big threats
against this Pawn by uh by the Knight
and by The Rook right now and if you
take a time out to defend
it feels like something's a bit wrong in
the right position I don't see
immediately is it Bishop B8 something to
do with this to kind of hit this Knight
well maybe black should be playing G6
pushing the queen back
or also these three might be opening the
diagonal I'm not sure about that and
after Queen F3 to play C5 C4 so my idea
is always to somehow block the bishop on
A2 and also Bishop B8 I like very much
maybe already in this position
to attack but yeah this would be quite
annoying for white
yeah this would be horrible for white uh
yeah no I wish
no we should no I shouldn't I shouldn't
do it
um okay but then there is some serious
pressure in the center and how are you
gonna handle that I do you have to go
like Rook 81 I think Rook 81 is maybe
the best move or that seems to be quite
a logical one you know just to protect
this bishop on D2 that was hanging in a
lot of lines there and uh we should also
point out to audience members who might
wonder why not take this Pawn on E5
the White Queen could for example
capture on E5 right now but the Black
Knight just jumps out the way with a
discovered attack a hit on the White
Queen and remember that this Knight also
hanging so one of those two pieces will
drop next move uh a loss of material so
yeah I'm expecting Rook a to D1 as well
and I'm not sure how uh tari here kind
of coordinates his pieces maybe you
bring the queen to a square you've kind
of centralized the black rook and you
just keep the tension and argue that
white is the one struggling to break out
in this position
black with more Central space yeah
loving the pawn structure here for black
in the center
I like the idea to start between D6 for
example
86 yeah I'm just not sure how white
improves to be honest I really want to
get off this diagonal but something like
G3 King G2 feels really slow
um
yeah I don't know maybe I try and
provoke you I'm stealing your ideas
Ivanka something like Bishop B4 hoping
that you kind of push and then I'll step
back hoping you push and then maybe
Queen D7 did also make a lot of sense
27 in the stop position as well yeah in
this position
yeah relying on tricks if the White
Queen ever steps onto the e-file with
quick takes E5 there's always Knight to
D4 yeah and somehow to go Rook a d8 as
as a plan and and and if you play Pawn
takes Pawn that would be also a big
howler
it's my nickname David howler and
because the Knight goes to D4 oh no no
no no no no F4 yeah but still it's not
winning because of Knight G3 ah and
after Knight D2 King H2 and after Knight
G3 F takes G3 oh wow beautiful variation
just to show the point Knight F4 there's
no time for quintix Queen because Knight
takes E2 would be a sufficient shock uh
intermediate check there and then you
regain the queen you've won a piece in
the process uh Judah found Knight G3
defending the White Queen not E2 trying
to deflect this white knight from the
protection of his Queen and Knight takes
Knight beautiful stuff still no time for
Queen takes Queen because Knight takes
Rook is a check but F takes G3 that was
some quick Vision that would have taken
me a few minutes to spot let alone uh
solve wow so okay tactics in the air but
uh watch out for something like this if
you're Nakamura I think Rook D1 will be
on the board it's a very type of
move to just maintain the tension keep
things kind of yeah in the balance as
long as possible and tari how will he
set up that's the big question roughly
level on time as well just looks
balanced the position uh I would think
who would you pick if you had to shoot
it well
Andrew venka
I'm gonna ask you both to commit that's
a good question
you want my prediction yeah
prediction evaluation
I do like aryan's position
but I don't
believe that he can take down Nakamura
so I think it will be a draw
I think they will go on in the
Armageddon okay
okay yeah birthday gift for tari I'm
gonna say blackwind just to spice things
up even though I do also believe in
Knuckles black women in this game or in
Armageddon oh I think if it goes to
Armageddon will take it I think
Hikaru is just too strong too quick so
Tori should be winning this one
the complete your prediction if he wants
that birthday to be complete
well there is nothing nicer than to win
against Nakamura on your birthday that's
for sure
yeah and uh okay well we'll leave you on
a cliffhanger there and should we go
back to the bird's eye view
yeah let's uh go and do a quick recap of
some of the other games I'm seeing a lot
of developments in the game uh between
those two teenage stars
and gukesh I think that's maybe the game
that's changed the most since we uh last
left it let's jump in there
and this one has simplified somewhat we
see them both deep in concentration and
while we jump in at a moment that Abdul
Satora finally on move 22 has just
castled with the white king
yeah leaving it a bit late I don't
recommend it at home usually you want to
Castle a bit earlier than this
especially on a safer side than this but
needs must sometimes and should we do a
quick recap how we got that let's uh
let's go back a bit because when we left
it was still closed
position it was still a close position
and we left it at this point white has
just regained the pawn on G7 and we were
looking at moves such as Queen to F6
hitting the Rook we were looking at King
f8 hitting the rook and various others
instead black chose to simplify in the
center D takes C4 clarifying the tension
there white of course recaptured that
pawn Knight V6 gaining Tempe time is of
the essence here the bishop drops back
black getting ready or at least hinting
that he might castle queenside and A4
nice threaten uh of an attack here this
Black Knight often misplaced on a square
like B6
C5 breaking out now from kakash really
nice Vision here D take C5 looks like it
wins a pawn for white but Queen E5 is a
double attack hitting the Rook hitting
the pawn and just to catch up with the
current position The Rook dropped back
Queen takes Pawn A5 the Black Knight
jumped in it was traded off and castles
what are we left with here it's back to
level material Knight versus Bishop
imbalance
I'm gonna put you on the spot again who
would you take here and why
with black to move
well first big question where to put the
black king can he cast sir right now
long side or black should be not
thinking about castling in this game
it's been answered for us it's happened
mirroring the opponent Castle there no
more questions no exactly
I mean it's the most natural move on the
board where I get your king to safety
but there is
some tension there in this on the d-line
and white go Rook D4
flashy Judith Rook D4 is possible here
uh let's jump in and show this on the
board it's not a sacrifice if Rook D4
happens because if it's captured Knight
to B5 is a check
and next move the queen is captured it's
important as well that Rook C8 is a pin
but the other white Rook can swing to
the rescue here Rook to C3 blocks that
and measures with extra material so Rook
D4 I guess black gives a check well if
Queen goes check I wanted to go Knight
to D1
discovery check check met by a check you
rarely see that and I guess I'll move
the king I could also block with the
bishop somehow yeah round with the King
or Bishop C6 you don't like Bishop C6
here I was slightly worried that you
would begin and win but Rook C8 goes out
the way
white pins then black pins and maybe
black wins
but yeah it's just so tense here
I have no idea who's better to be honest
uh suddenly I slightly prefer black in
this position because the black King's
slightly safer yeah and the bishop will
stand very well on C6 or even to go to
B5
so maybe it was just a nice move nice
try but nothing more than that but that
does beg the question in this position
shooter you mentioned Rook D4 if black
has nothing better than Queen F1 white
could actually repeat if you really want
to Rook back to D1 yeah but actually you
have after Rook D4 I think mean C7 can
be a nice move attacking on A5 and also
Bishop C6 is preparing that somehow the
bishop stands incredibly well on C6
because the White Knight will not have
such an amazing square
uh in this position I think and also
white has some weaknesses I mean Pawn on
A5 it can be very tricky yeah I agree
and so that's why I would be tempted so
if the E4 is on there
oh wow amazing spot the equations cannot
slip this away and you get a double
exclamation brilliant reward two weeks
left wow
you should be playing here dude I want
to see it Rook D4 what a move and it
gets the double exclamation mark because
it's brilliant and unexpected it is a
sacrifice as well or at least
visually a sacrifice
and Moment of Truth will black just give
that check that we mentioned where the
position might repeat or drop back if
you want but actually maybe it is a good
move because there is nothing better
than that right yeah
yeah actually if White's kind of second
best move was to for example Shuffle the
king towards the corner then that
doesn't improve the position yeah
because the queen on C4 actually stands
uh very well and very active so if black
would be able to play Bishop C6 and
control the D file then black is
incredibly active and from C4 after
Bishop C6 Queen B4 can be also a move so
that's uh I think it's important for
black to for white to push away the
queen so now I'm curious whether isn't
going to be Rook D1 first
or
I'm not happy to go back with the Knight
yeah I love what kokesh has done
actually I love the fact that he's
thrown in a check immediately even if he
wants to play for a win even if he wants
to play on by retreating The Black Queen
to C7 it's nice that he's kind of uh
flicked in this question first he's
asking Abdul sotorov his intentions but
also it's a power move it's like if you
repeat twice then you're the one to play
on for a win you immediately assert your
psychological dominance over the
opponent and the number of times that's
worked out uh kind of in uh throughout
chess history it's yeah definitely a boy
to be utilized and I remember when I was
a kid I didn't understand people who
made repetition of moves and then they
deviated yeah and of course I understood
after some time carpo for example he
could never resist a repeating once a
move right and it happened quite a few
times with me that my opponent made a
move I was hesitating and then my
opponent just made the repetition and I
said oh I was spending like 15 minutes
for this
yeah
so I can only advise to everybody if you
can make a repetition of moves that's
the best thing because one you can make
your opponent think and after he's
thinking and you're going back it's a
frustration for the opponent secondly in
most of the event you have bonus time so
at least you can gain maybe 30 seconds
or a minute just repeating one move
there and back and we have a repetition
here yes and we're going to see the
queen drop back
no other way you have to drop back to C4
and now I'm going to see 56
. did he go back to C4 he went back to
C4 the queen A6 felt very shaky I
wouldn't touch that one with a barge
pole and
and again even if your intention is
Queen A6 you should repeat first before
going back and then Queen A6 look at
this are the youngsters going to be
repeating moves and go for the
Armageddon This Is The Moment of Truth
look at this double exclamation mark
again for Rook D4 we've seen it before
uh this is a brilliant game so far but
he goes back okay guess there's no
he shows that he shows it
I don't want to draw like this I want to
fight it out until the very end yeah oh
look at that boss move rejects the draw
stands up gets away from the board he
knows uh that psychological battle right
right but if you kind of see the
momentum good cash was under pressure
from Lorde back from the opening okay he
survived that and when we look at the
clock times you'll also see the norda
back now 40 minutes the norderbeck is
having a tough tournament so far you
know he managed to defeat our antari in
a classical game but it was shaky to say
the least and ever since then you know
he's gone to Armageddon and lost that
why not play for the win and after all
white in addition if you were to look at
the board does have a very weak Pawn on
A5
right now there is a provocation by
black because now black is asking you
know what I'm playing for a win I have
no problem in this position are you
gonna play B4 or what are you going to
be playing oh B4
it makes some sense here because the
white king might actually find a nice
safe Square on B2 where the white Pawn
currently stands well I'm thinking that
after B4 black is going to be playing
Queen C7 and I want to exchange the
Queens don't worry yeah
I don't want to be having the the Queens
on the board
yeah should we jump in just to show this
uh because B4 it might be needed sooner
or later as you said you did this a pawn
is
eternally weak now for white so why not
defend it with gain of time you hit the
black queen again don't take this Rook
because of night check and uh next move
this queen drops off so Queen C7 and a
move like King B2 maybe a move to the
truth I don't really understand why
Queen C5 was played by gokash and not
Queen C7 immediately
I have to be honest here B4 is an
unexpected move because you know you're
traditionally taught you shouldn't push
your Pawns in front of your king
it doesn't follow the classical
guidelines but I agree with you I mean
my inkling was get the queen far away
get her close to the king
yeah because B4 once you get over as you
say Ivanka kind of any Prejudice here
any kind of uh just kind of stereotypes
about pushing bones in front of your
king then suddenly you see okay here for
example let's say Rook D3 I just uh King
V8 King B2 something just normal moves
maybe there's something stronger there
for white but it feels like at least
you've coordinated right but this is the
thing that before it's a provocation by
gokash but I'm not sure that V4 is not
on White's favor exactly everything
protects each other now everything's
nice and harmonious these pawns and you
know what is an incredible beautiful
Square for the White Queen it's D2
travel up I love the square for the
queen on D2 because Blackwing cannot go
to E5 because I'm gonna play F4
and it's a very stable position for
white
yeah just for example Queen D2 and yeah
Queen E5 always met by F4 T2 controlling
the D file
wow and uh yeah we should just go back
just uh to mention if B4 does happen
Queen takes D4 Knight B5 check King V8
Knight takes Rook C8 is met by Rook C3
but then Rook takes C3 is possible here
is this a difference
but I'm not sure it's so great for black
king D2 yeah King D2
can't be what I mean even if I take on
C8 and I play E5 it's only white who can
play for a while yeah maybe this is a
classier way of doing it total lockdown
yeah it's very important to look uh the
pawns on the right squares what a
beautiful King detericking F working G5
you can dream around
with such a knight on D4 nice tactic
there but actually it would backfire on
black if he went for it
wow instructive stuff going on right now
provocation but maybe uh unnecessary
provocation at the same time if you look
at the body language of the players you
can see that gokash has this that I know
what I'm doing I have no problem and I'm
still trying to get a little bit out of
this with black and of the center of I
have a feeling that it's somehow he
feels uncomfortable right now at this
point that he he thought that there
would be a repetition of moves and he's
going off and play the Armageddon but
gokash is a player who is always out
there to fight he doesn't want to make
repetition of moves he wants to improve
this way that he always wants to go on
and learn and learn and learn
yeah that's good advice for all the
younger players out there or all the
players kind of uh who maybe aren't
playing chess full time just why worry
about the result a draw you won't
remember a draw at the end of your
career you'll remember the times you
fought and won even if you take a few
losses on the way you learn right and uh
I mean I had this rule until I was in my
early 20s just always play till the end
even if it backfired a lot I must say I
learned a lot along the well I had the
feeling that it turned out to be very
beneficial for you because you became a
great Grandmaster ah too kind but yeah I
mean I see this happening now more and
more and it's definitely a trend right
yeah I mean this is the way you're
learning right I mean if if you make a
drawing a drawing equalish position
what's the point you want to try out
test yourself right also that can I can
I create something why not and if they
they have the self-confidence right yeah
so they say okay it's equal position why
should I be making repeating moves I'm
going to play show me that you have
something right I agree I mean this is
the path to Improvement
however the path to enjoyment
is a bit different
sometimes it's good to be a big fish in
a little pond
[Laughter]
I've enjoyed some of my losses just as
much as some of those short drawers no
no short drawers no short drawers we
answer that and there's going to be no
short drawers here in Norway because it
is the home of fighting Jazz and one
game I'd like to revisit because well I
can say one thing about it we did have a
bet in the studio and David Howe won
that bet because Anish did capture on D5
with the pawn so let's head there yeah I
might have won the betters to what move
would happen but I'm also scared that
Judith's prediction will be correct that
it will backfire on a niche and we see
this position in front of us let's just
backtrack two or three moves to see how
we got there there was that huge moment
Anish invested a lot of time we see him
down at half an hour left now on the
clock and it was back here after Knight
takes D5 I correctly predicted e takes
D5 which is yeah maybe the uh kind of I
don't know say lazier move but it's the
easier move to calculate the downside is
that Magnus was allowed to push forward
with E6 and it's 2 scary to recapture or
take this Pawn because the White Queen
gets into the position on E6 Anish had
Rook f8 prepared but suddenly Magnus
okay opened up one side of the board
after A4 and after a trade of Rooks on
the a file looks like he's getting ready
to take this Pawn the question is
whether he takes it immediately or
whether he goes for it with his Bishop
or what do we think here Bishop to H3 or
queen takes Pawn should we have another
bet
big moment feels like the black king
does like Defenders all of White's
pieces Master around the king side
I'm going to go for the building move
Bishop H3 because this is very much in
magnus's style you know he improves his
worst place piece he likes to invite
everyone to the proverbial party
and it looks good right you bring in a
new piece to attack
it does look good I'm slightly curious
as to why Magnus kind of traded off
Rooks on the a file maybe he's just
arguing that this black Bishop on A8 is
so far away from the defense right now
maybe he's saying he didn't need that
Rook on A1 anyway
but blacks will still be a pawn up in
the resulting positions at least for a
while
I think I would try Queen E6
it's a check it's the first move we
calculate okay after King goes out I
don't know sure
yeah yeah H7 feels open
it's on an open diagonal so my question
is what about Knight E5 and I do think
the same with you David that the bishop
on A8 is very important that it's far
away if it would be on B7 it would be a
much better opportunities to defend
later at some point Bishop C8 maybe he
will have the time to come back but I
think for the moment it's important
tempo for white so I would go for an id5
and I would exchange that one faster
that you can say anything yeah before it
lands exactly it's going to land on F7
or G6 and
get that out of my field I wouldn't
think that you would allow me to stay
there for long okay so which way do you
want to recapture porn open up the white
Rook give it a drop to do I want to go
Bishop H6 that's my secret we should
actually point out uh we'll come back to
this position just two moves ago Bishop
takes H6 looks like it might be a nice
sacrifice to open things up but I guess
black has the Mover up to F6 uh with a
hit on the White Queen and on the bishop
as well uh so Knight to E5 first and now
suddenly threats of Bishop takes D5
sometimes Bishop takes H6
I'm scared I must admit the don't be
scared it's not your game
but I have the bet on the line I I would
have felt bad for jinxing Anish if I
said if I say he takes D5 and he crashes
to defeat and queen E6 is on the board
yeah this position looks good I must say
for white uh unless black has some
miraculous defense here
I'm slightly tempted to stop H7
without hesitation King H7 oh wow
scared of these Bishop takes H6 ideas
maybe that's why I wanted to put the
King on H7 it's understandable but on H7
we all know that it can also be some
tricky stuff on the white square yeah
you know any check on this diagonal will
likely be deadly for black for example
Bishop H3 and go to F5 something but I
don't like it when you push back my
queen with Rook F6
and the reason is maybe he went to H7
that after Knight E5 you can go maybe
Rook F6 ah so you don't have to take it
because otherwise Knight F7 check was
there
right but maybe I just I don't know
maybe D5 I can take ah this Pawn
Under Fire six is not possible
wow so I guess the difference would be
95 let's assume black captures this uh
beautiful piece maybe maybe can can go
Queen D6 with black
oh wow tactics instead of Knight E5
uh after 95 yeah 26
yeah you forced me back I guess yes but
that's not the reason I had I wanted to
get to E6 to go back afterwards
now black maybe can even take this
Knight off the board
and slide across the G6 to defend yeah
it feels like black has enough resources
uh can white keep the pieces on that's
the question this is the current
position in the game
Bishop H3 you mentioned but then Rook F6
what else could Magnus try
it should be five I was thinking but
then Queen C8 or what's there can I go
Bishop E5
yeah so you mentioned Queen chrys trying
to get the Queens off at any cost looks
logical
yeah the problem is now taking this Pawn
will backfire I guess in multiple ways
maybe it's the queen trapped
well this is going to be I just want to
play this and try and trap your queen do
you have any Escape squares I'm going to
this Square just to cover B5 you can
take you can take the bishop oh no but
it drops a piece anyhow in the end
be a piece down just to show this trick
so King H7 is a very concrete approach
yeah
nice move there for Manish uh just looks
scary indeed but if we need to back
really calm I want to go Knight E5 yeah
and some checks good circumstances or
queen E3 we need to what somehow I want
to keep this option for the queen to go
check from C2
yeah it feels count intuitive but again
if Magnus sees nothing better then it
makes sense to kind of get the queen out
of the way
first and only attack later I'm really
attracted to the special H3 move I've
got to say but I can't tell you why
another idea is well Bishop H3 also H5
Maybe
that's a Magnus move he loves fixing
pawns H5 and after Rook F6 to come back
somewhere E3 E2
but uh one of the downsides with the
root coming to F6 is that the Knight can
jump into E5 with power
yes
I agree with that featured chat by the
way Magnus is so proactive right now his
uh pieces uh looks so threatening that
black would love any exchanges so yeah
Anish Rook F6 may be in the pipeline
Bishop D6 Queen C8 some various ideas to
kick back White's pieces
uh it's fascinating that this type of
position the evaluation Bar says it's
completely level despite the fact it's
so Dynamic and black is still a pawn up
remember any end games will favor Black
due to the presence of the B and C Pawns
oh this one feels very wild I mean it's
very very tense right now so let's go
back to the bird's eye view and have a
look at some of our other games and the
one that I really had my eye on is of
course fabulous Fabi tournament leader
10 and a half points out of 12.
but he is a pawn down against chakra
mamajarov
hey and uh this is important for the
standings of course mama jarov
defending extremely tenaciously we've
got to say after being surprised in the
opening and I also see the clock times
fabies not at the board right now but he
is 20 minutes down on the clock and upon
down as you mentioned Ivanka could we
see a shake-up now if Favi crashes to
defeat and uh also Judah you mentioned I
think two hours ago this A3 Pawn it's
disappeared The Black Queen now sits on
A3 and any end game will favor Black
this time due to the presence of this
apron oh absolutely and we know that the
time is a very important part of the
game especially here because the players
are going to receive only extra time
second then second after move 40 and
then Fabiano was in our studio he was
expressing this the time is very tricky
here and he has much less time than mama
jorov so probably there is something
went wrong for him I believe that he was
engaged so much and spending so much
time for now indeed black just captured
or uh or before the pawn
yeah should we try to digest what's
happened and also try and figure out
where fappy went wrong absolutely the
evaluation bar now on black side uh to
go with the uh time advantage to boot so
the position we have now was reached
just within three moves actually of when
we last left this game uh we predicted
that Rook D6 a few times ago would land
and it did land very powerfully actually
rotates D6 we saw a rook trade Queen to
H4 C6 I believe you predicted this judic
just taking away the Square from uh
White's Bishop now Bishop D5 will never
come with a pin this Pawn is definitely
threatened now and after Bishop
retreating to D3 simply grabbing a Pawn
on A3 black now
yeah getting active with the queen and
queen to G3 last move well we can see
that after Queen G3 the threat is Bishop
takes G6 Queen G3 Bishop F7
for example right so black is going to
be making yeah on a three I think this
works
and now white has huge threats of
pushing forward the e-pawn
so nice tactic there big threat on the
board how does black guard against this
I'm I'm just kind of instinct twice
looking at dropping back with the black
queen well that's the most natural move
to go locate y e pawn and also you have
the advantage of preventing any
potential repetitions or Bishop takes
porn as David highlighted
but I think after Queen E7 if we can
make it on the board I think H4 is the
continuation because for now Bishop E6
is not possible to Bishop F5
wow nice geometry there after H4 Bishop
takes E6 Bishop F5 and two pins ensure
the win pin on the G file depend on the
e-file and white wins the black Bishop
uh nice that Drew did so H4 you
mentioned
welcome black do let's say I just make a
move
um Rook d8 King G7 instead of taking G7
are you playing H5
H5 which actually King G7 was a bit of a
clumsy one because now I've given you H6
yes yes you're not going to be happy
with that one now your King's always
going to get checkmated on the back rank
so uh just to show as well the viewers
King takes H6 will backfire after Queen
check and checkmate
so it's still some danger and H4 just
typical nowadays this is definitely what
fabi's banking on uh Alpha zero type of
Pawn push
I should say I shouldn't say Alpha zero
type of Pawn push it's just a good move
but it's interesting before we were
calling H4 like bent Larsen move when
you sacrifice it was tall or you make
these typical moves right share style
and then now these days you call it
Alpha zero style it's a stockfish move
yeah so maybe retreating isn't the best
what else could uh Shaq be thinking
about other than dropping his Queen back
to E7
um could you also the thing is though E7
is always in the air so I do quite like
the queen E7 but I just think that you
have to be a bit more precise when H4
comes and maybe ideas of F5
F5 okay and if white continues motoring
forward
you just want to kind of Round Up This
Pawn at some point that was the plan
okay six for E6
but uh but if Rook F6 I mean there was
this idea of going Queen to B8
diving
diving in
yeah still so many resources for Fabi we
can't rule him out
and there is also sometimes an idea
let's say instead of a H5 to play C5 and
block the C6 and B7 pawns over there and
Bishop B6 is not necessarily possible to
Bishop C4 at least that was my idea
but maybe Rook F6 and number seven and
yeah just die yourself
it's funny how both of us made that same
gesture well it's like you've huddled
yourself into a little ball yes boxing
yourself or I don't know how to say just
looks like zuk Swang but maybe for both
sides but black has two extra points
obviously on the the side of the the
board the bar says probably zero zero
zero yep Alpha zero Style
I'm curious now okay like
okay so in this position it says
that black is better
but only after the move F5 which is
something that we stumbled upon but in a
different context
wow so F5 will give black the advantage
and the whole idea is to cut out Bishop
takes G6 tactics now there's no Bishop
takes G6 and I guess also in some
positions you can start to threaten F4
and let's see if white plays H4 what
could the idea be here
for black it says Queen to C3
look that's that's like a Maurice Ashley
geometric move yeah actually white has
the problem of loose pieces where to put
this Rook if you put it on a bad Square
then things could backfire also this
Pawn is very fast what what is flying
rookie too and you start pushing the
pawns maybe although White's also
pushing it's a bit of a race
yeah this is extremely difficult to find
we should mention I'm not sure how
natural F5 is uh manager might find it
but even following up with Queen C3 even
following up from that position we
mentioned Judith not not sir entirely
obvious right
Yes actually I like both of the moves I
was thinking for a second before you
told the F5 yawanka to play Queen B4 and
put pressure on the Rock that's what I
had in mind that maybe that also makes
sense but I like F5 a lot because to
block the all these opportunities in the
future to play Bishop G6 it's something
great if E7 doesn't work and it seems so
that E7 doesn't work because of rookie 8
and the Queen
uh can't go to the to the right Square
maybe Queen E3 with again black go King
F7 or what's going on here maybe F4 if
F4 I thought just goes uh Aquin E4
Bishop F5 yeah something along these
lines maybe the queen drops D4 Queen D4
uh-huh
it's tactical Queen d8 ideas in there
yeah it's so hard I think even in this
position even with a 20 minute time
Advantage Chuck uh it's easy to go wrong
if white gets one more moves yeah it
will split
yeah and uh that one is also perfectly
good it's just that uh
black has a very minimal Advantage yeah
we should point out that he's uh
basically allowing this trick right
Judith uh Bishop takes G6 but he must
have something up his sleeve here is it
just the end game Bishop takes G6 but
okay it's a little different because the
Rook will be standing blockading the
pawn on E6 right sorry first
king G7
thanks and then Rook E7
it looks kind of dangerous for black
history C5 C5 yeah yeah
yeah
interesting stuff I guess these ideas F5
and then maybe King F6 and take this
Pawn
feels like we might head to some drawers
Rook end game somehow but the thing is
if we don't play C5 but let's say play
G4 to stop F5 but then B5 I think very
strong
so complex
important game in the standings this one
yeah and I was just wondering after
shark's last move
it looks to me like Bishop takes Pawn is
forced because otherwise Chuck is just
simply going to pick up the pawn on E6
the end
yeah Black's just threatening
how else to deal with it
so what happens if H4
can you let's say I take with the
something let's say I take with the Rook
Ace okay okay take take
you wanted Queen B8 or H5 first I want
the H5 first yeah H5 maybe I have a
check and I go back to E5 yeah
next move for example if you move the
king
Queen E5 I have to go Queen B8 track
before yeah this is awful
between B8 I mean at the very least I
can go back with the King maybe I just
kind of let you take my pawn and then I
just say okay I'll curl up and this a
pawn it's a winner could be winner
winner chicken dinner
I've had that phrase now in my mind for
like three months are you the source of
that I don't know I think that's the
first time I've ever said that phrase in
my life so I don't know why it came to
mind but uh it could be a winner and the
chicken dinner afterwards for Shaq if he
wins this Pawn on E6
I think we have to allow Fabi to think
here Bishop takes G6 uh looks like the
only route towards wow I say safety but
relative safety right now for Fabi he
needs to pull the brakes Maybe by going
into an end game
um maybe mama will uh will make the
tournament interesting allow other
people trying to catch getting closer to
Fabi but I have to say Fabi does have a
very commanding lead and the nearest
rival is Hikaru Nakamura with six and a
half points so he can allow himself one
slip up
yeah but you know how it is if if let's
say we're just playing analyzing the
opportunities let's say mommy jarro wins
over Fabiano in a classical game he
still stands that and a half Nakamura
wins he has already nine and a half so
everything is open after that if
something like this would happen yeah
and one loss and confidence disappears
momentum changes uh yeah that would be
devastating for Fabi he's been by far
the player of the tournament but uh of
course one move now one slip and that
could all change well of course he's
still far away from loss it's just uh
playing with an idea that when you're in
round five no matter how much lead you
have if you start losing games it's uh
it's going to disappear the advantage
it's absolutely true you know we have to
remind ourselves of the scoring system
if you win in the classical game then
you get three points whereas if you win
your match in the Armageddon only one
and a half points so a string of
classical victories and Bob's your uncle
you might be there at the top Bishop G6
on the on the board
yeah often if we give the top players
just one move a narrow path they'll find
it right just process of elimination a
bit of calculation there and I'm still
wondering what is his plan after Queen
G3 Bishop F7 King goes to uh G7
takes back on G3
and rookie seven because that's a kind
of a crucial moment whether is he going
to be allowing F5
or
but I'm pretty sure that white is not
going to be losing this game yeah it
feels like you should be able to draw I
see that in the feature chat Rook takes
E6 double exclamation mark could that be
true so this end game feels like it
could go either way uh while Bishop
takes G6 and the fact that Shaq has
paused means that there is an option
quintix Queen maybe not obligatory well
it takes E6 what on Earth is that put it
on the board yeah tricky stuff back rank
Checkmate threatened no time to win the
white uh to take the black queen there
sorry and of course no time to take the
Rook either because you check on this
Square not on A1 I was about to put
Queen A1 on the board but suddenly
whoops discovered check and um
but uh black of course is the one doing
the mating after Quincy one and next
move is Checkmate on the back rank ah
what a move rookie six
key six and they're all sorts of Bishop
moves discovered attacks here
you could kind of take this Pawn jump
out the way with a check you can drop
back to D3 maybe with a discover check
well isn't that the only move maybe
unless we want to sacrifice and kind of
go all in this is a track
I'm not sure where the black king runs
and hides
let's say f8 temporarily I'd say f8 and
some tension now but maybe in our Rook
E6 it should be six Queen B8 check
we should point out that now there's no
back rank because White's Bishop can
drop back and block and Rook E6 on the
board wow wow Shack
okay so this variation we're showing
it's extremely relevant Bishop takes E6
we're expecting Queen B8 check and
who knows at this point White's gonna
win a second Pawn back so it's going to
be material equality and again it comes
down to this a pawn is that going to be
a winner of the chicken dinner or is it
going to be simply a distraction
right now root takes E6 let's put it
back on the board
is fabi's move forced does he have to
drop back to D3 break the connection
between these queens and
five by the way you just go hang out
yeah
I missed that one Judith I think maybe
fabulous that one Bishop no because
maybe you can sacrifice and go Queen G3
Bishop takes takes takes Bishop C4
check yeah wow who's better here and why
yeah that's uh isn't black much better
here three postpones that's a winner for
me it looks like it should be either
winning or not at all and the evaluation
bar does confirm it's some Advantage at
least in Blitz you to take black hair
every time the white king too far away
yeah okay so Bishop F5 is not an option
six
it's got to be Bishop D3 and kind of
seek chances
on the board yeah exactly on the board
now Bishop D3 check
Discovery and where to go you could
maybe make an argument for
wait let me calculate F7
does that get out of all those checks
dude that we were talking about King f 7
nice Queen C7 right yeah Queen C7 I know
rookie seven doesn't work 27. no you can
go rookie a queen E7 yeah on the board
yeah
Queen E7 and white just has to trade
pieces although A5 is
hanging at the end oh actually wait no
it's not hanging at the end wow what a
mess after King h8 is on the board okay
strange that he barely paused for
thought he wants to go Bishop G8 you
know after rookie six takes Queen B8
Bishop G8
wow
contortion Style just curl up into a
ball like we were talking about earlier
hiding out in the corner hitting this
bishop so white doesn't have time to go
Pawn hunting
King h8 really clever stuff from Shaq
there he must have calculated this all
from afar but what could the downside be
the evaluation bar did react slightly
in White's favor there
well
this is getting intense and I think this
is the perfect time to take a pause
because it is break time and of course
we do have to mention a special
opportunity the 2023 speed chess season
begins with the junior speed Chess
Championship on June the 13th this four
day event showcases the best young
talent in speed chess with over 45
000 on the line but the real prize goes
to the top finisher alone who moves on
to the main speed Chess Championship
later this summer catch all the action
starting June the 13th right here at
twitch.tv forward slash chess use
x-clamp jscc in chat for all the details
and we'll be back right after this break
Armageddon is lurking around the corner
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the bow tennis
sisters come on look at this oh
the chess.com Community streamer program
is growing every day
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
we're here in Toronto for the global
Championship I got Fabiana carwana with
me you don't need to talk yet I got
James we're gonna see who recognizes
these guys out of the out of the random
passerbys and we're gonna ask them some
fun questions about Chess for five bucks
do you know who this is
no okay active an actor well you see
this guy
any idea who he is somebody very famous
he is
this is actually 50 Cent's brother his
name is Daryl that's right it goes by
75. you want to play chess okay so what
is he a player or something obsess
he is a chess player I'm not but he is
yeah I play on the side yeah I've been
taking some coaching lessons from
Grandmaster Canty over here recently
over your calculation over everything
what's your name again sir uh my name is
Jamie what's your name
I already know it it's uh it's Daniel
yeah Daniel nerdinsky okay
there it is come on on the attack baby
on the attack if he wins I know the guys
at chess.com we'll get him a diamond
membership okay do you know what that is
yes okay is that something you want yes
yeah okay look at you look is this a
London yo we got a pro here with the
London
how'd it go
I should have said youtube.com
csq pod what is the URL of this YouTube
actually don't remember okay
look at the pot
[Music]
foreign
Norway land of fjords Majestic mountains
Cliffs and waterfalls
in addition to stunning geography Norway
is home to the greatest chess player who
has ever lived Magnus Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best from Carlson's fiercest online
rival today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps laude Beck
abdusotorov and kukesh domaraju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023 Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana two more long-time
Headliners seek to take their next turn
Atop A major tournament Wesley so and
Shakira mamag yarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field who will
come out on top will Carlson run the
table yet again or will someone else
usurp the throne this
is Norway chess
welcome back and I hope you're refreshed
and ready after that short pause because
I have to say the games are getting
interesting especially as we March
towards those shorter time controls and
let's have a look at the bird's eye view
to see what games take our fancy so
we've we've saw a lot of wild
complications in the matchup between
Fabiana caruana and Shakura mamajarov
but it's also Brewing everywhere else as
well and one game that really does catch
my eye is the one in the middle because
Wesley we've been talking about it for
quite a while has actually pushed his F
Pawn forward and attacks the knight in
order to get central dominance you two
are grundfeld experts so to me this
looks great for whites am I misreading
the position well at first it definitely
seems to be very good for white if the
Black Knight would be going back to D7
if we can jump into some of the lines
and the if the Knight moves back then of
course immediately E5 and it looks like
white has an immense position but can he
go Knight CC yeah this is what I wanted
to say Knight C6 because this was a
moment where black had to make a right
decision and it's very important that
there is a pin on the day file now the
B4 Bishop attacked and something will
end up in the next move on D4 either the
Knight or the bishop I believe
yeah also this E4 Pawn is often hanging
in certain variations a problem for here
for Wesley so how does he get his Bishop
out of the way he drops it back to C3
and uh here Judy you mentioned that
something could end up in D4 be that a
knight or a bishop are there
Alternatives could you for example trade
off and then I mean possibly take this
Pawn
on e4 well I think one of the question
how do you want to take the pawn right
now immediately right now there's a pawn
up for grabs guys
just take it please let's check it out
Queen takes E4 just while this is still
pinned
and yeah the problem is for example the
white Bishop could move with gain of
time but at the very least black could
now take this bishop and get the Queens
off the board yeah exactly and black is
great yeah black is cruising maybe even
winning this position so uh yeah if we
go back
after Bishop C3
Queen takes E4 why not
I don't see any downside yet
um do we have to do any calculation here
other than that I mean I don't know
maybe fight can take on F6 and then to
play Rook D1 to protect the pawn not
allowing Queen D4 or Knight D4 and and
white says that okay I'm going to have
D6 I have a great bishop and my pawn my
d-pawn is a much stronger postpone than
yours and okay white gave up a pawn
right I think you've uh yeah you found
it you stumbled across the maybe the
only way for white to defend everything
else looked pretty Grim to be honest and
yeah if we could teleport this Black
Knight kind of put it in a time machine
just put it on D6 somehow blockade that
white Pawn then black would be winning
but unfortunately uh it does look like
White's counter play very quick
yeah I'd like that in the future chat
when it comes to pawn grabbing no
calculations E4 done I like how I'm in
the majority here
I think new members to the ah I'm
recruiting as we speak
yeah and suddenly Knight E7 white could
dream maybe of pushing D6 the Knight can
move and maybe even D7 just put it all
the way up uh the board and
yeah but I think black should be doing
very fine in this scenario as well so I
don't know if after Queen E4 is there
anything else white can come up with but
it seems so that the threat of Bishop
exchange and queen D4 check it's
something white cannot meet with any
anything else than to capture on F6 and
and Rook D1 I believe
to me it looks like the only way so
we're here we're expecting Queen takes
porn and Rook to D1 Q move and the game
continues we could well see a scenario
eventually where the kind of Queens get
exchange the bishop and Knight come off
as well and we get down to a rook end
game where black will have an extra Pawn
but these doubled F pawns won't Maybe
Can't for that much
so yeah we'll see maybe Wesley can hold
the balance here but Farish has done a
good job it must say of uh finding these
tactical tricks I I I agree and well we
will see we'll kind of move
mood that Wesley is in and breaking news
we have the first result of the day it
looks like a draw between nordebec Abdus
and gukesh and we left that one with the
queen still on the board it did fizzle
out shall we investigate what happened
there yeah let's have a quick look and
then we have some other important games
going on with some action
yeah so first result that means
Armageddon in roughly 15 minutes uh
maybe 20 minutes time between those two
youngsters that's going to be fast and
it's going to be fun to watch but uh
meanwhile this was the final position
and before we dig deeper into this let's
go back to where we left it we left it
at Queen C5 earlier white simply
retreated the Night Safety First move
just forcing the Queens off the board
due to this c-file pin maybe before it's
too late White had to backpedal here uh
Queen's coming off E5 hitting the Rook
F6 solidifying the center and F4 I think
a really nice move actually here Abdus
because black was about to take over
white was in serious danger or after
Bishop C6 Bishop C6 happened anyway but
this was met calmly by capturing
everything off the board and we saw the
position of fizzle after F takes E5 wow
good cash actually offering a draw after
earlier turning down the charts to
repeat because after Rook takes E5 he
probably figured that uh this one is
just
dead level pawns symmetrical almost and
uh yeah this one down in Armageddon now
well actually well actually I'm kind of
surprised I find that they agree to draw
but probably they were both ready in
their mindset okay go cash was trying to
play on and showing that he wants to go
a little further in the game or that's
also possible that he thought there is a
better Innovation with white in a later
stage which she didn't like so that's
why he went Queen C5 the bottom line is
that shortly we are going to see an
incredible
Armageddon I think yeah and what are we
predicting for that encounter
your cash was so good yesterday against
Magnus
he sent very much on the opening
mm-hmm
what if you put me in the corner as I
will
nobody puts Judah in the corner then I
say
good question
uh Kakashi was so good against Magnus so
unlucky yesterday but I'll say Abdus
just for argument's sake
I am also thinking that good cash will
win because it was so close against
Magnus and
nordebec hasn't been doing so well in
the armageddon's he's lost them all so
and he's in a must win situation yes
so we will see in 20 minutes their Fates
will be decided by Armageddon and let's
head back to the bird's eye view
and see what other games
oh I'm very curious to see what
what Nakamura is up to versus the
birthday boy
now
yeah this game the center has exploded
Judith uh suddenly all sorts of tricks
in the uh black has beautiful
centralization but Nakamura has a few
threats potentially up his sleeve so
maybe let's check out how this game has
evolved and reassess whether we still
think it's in the balance
birthday boy Ariana he's got some
questions to answer and the clocks are
ticking it's now down to under 30
minutes for both sides and we're only at
move 22 so still oceans of time a long
uh kind of list of moves ahead before
any increment what I don't understand
exactly why the Rook stands on B8 format
let me see that what has happened how
did that get there yeah so last we left
this game Let's jump in and do an action
replay we left it after Black Brook out
in the center with D5 and after D5 white
actually traded off releasing the
tension immediately and slightly
surprising to me that Ariane captured
with the Knight I thought he would
simply take back with the pawn uh
opening the C file for the black Rook
but nope he took with the Knight and
after Rook to E1 Queen E6 the White
Queen dropped back and after Knight G3
the threatening to jump in with the
white knight Black Block this with
Knight to D4 uh covering this Square
Bishop five and this is the answer to
your question Judah The Rook was hit
from the white Bishop so he simply moved
it and NACA Retreats back to E3 so I
guess very direct plan of taking this
Knight off the board and jumping into F5
how does Aryan deal with that one
yeah now it seems to me that there are
quite a few questions which black has to
answer Queen G6 was just played trying
to exchange the Queens at first it looks
like a nice move covering the F5 Square
trying to exchange the Queens I would
love it for black if white would capture
on G6 phone would capture it with from
H7 towards to the center and later on to
play F5 and still both of the knights
are standing really beautiful
at the same time can a white go C3 the
only reason I don't like the fact that
the A7 Bishop is unprotected I would
love to have more The Rook on a to
protect that Bishop so I don't know
what's uh going on here should black be
taking on E3 and after F takes E3 go
Knight E6 might have to and here there
is another attack suddenly opened up we
talked about the light squared Bishop
all the way uh earlier at the start of
the game Hikari so it's about that let's
go with Bishop double attack so 96
forced Judith and this is the key
question is black okay here
feels like it should be good for white
if you can kind of get D4 and Knight E4
in and start jumping but maybe Black's
just solid enough I wanted the same
question with the Queens on the board
could we ask here what happens after C3
is this a slightly better version maybe
I just once I kind of want the Queens on
if black ever trades the Queens I'm very
happy actually with this chain sorry
Mouse slip not Queen G5 this uh trade
because suddenly white feels like has
extra control over this Square this
Square
maybe just D4 well the move order had to
be Queen exchange first otherwise Bishop
C Bishop F7 I guess oh sorry yeah let's
uh we want to get this position right
uh it takes the E4 it takes the E4
I would love to take Knight D4 but the
F7 is still under attack
otherwise the grab three pawns with the
Knight D4 takes Bishop D4 Bishop B2 that
would be a great compensation for black
but kind of you you can't just sit with
your knight onto G5 and just say
maybe you can go uh five maybe yeah C5
and yeah after push now G5 yeah I mean
if push then suddenly this white Bishop
is locked out as well actually check
first yeah first yeah yeah
and yeah after the king moves then
Knight G5 or Knight C5 and yeah go to D3
why has a dead piece yeah that would be
too nice for black yeah this could be a
key detail because it looks like black
was suffering unless you had the C5
break and looks like Aryan has worked it
all out let's go back to the current
position can black can white go Queen D1
does it make any sense or uh then Knight
E3 would be much better for black
because the G3 Knight is also under
attack
wow it looks like a fascinating position
regardless I want to go straight to the
Magnus game because he's just come out
of the confessional and he said
and he should surprise me
so what has Anish done to surprise
Magnus
[Music]
um
uh
uh declart best
um
[Music]
and uh there we see Magnus confessing to
having been surprised by anisha's Queen
D6 and is this a judge adjustment that
Magnus talks about how he was felt like
he was winning and now oh not that easy
anymore
and to me it's just a classic case of
one of the top players just being really
confident about their chances when in
reality I think just it looks like a
logical game neither side has done
anything too spectacular I'm surprised
that Magnus is so optimistic I've got to
say normally we see him kind of
downplaying his chances saying okay like
he played fine but the opponent also
played okay
do we agree with his thoughts here I
don't know if I do actually I would like
to go back exactly to this moment where
he was referring to that he was blunder
and queen D6
at the point where he thought he's
already winning
and because I think we were looking this
uh moment before
yes so this was the reason he went to
King H7 right to play Queen D6 this is
what we discussed because we also
underestimated and we were not really
spending serious time on King H7 because
ah it looks bad put it on the white
square diagram right but actually it had
a very concrete idea behind it
and queen D6 was missed by Magnus now he
wants to keep the Queens on at any cost
he wants the attack to continue to boil
so Queen G4 retreating we saw a trade
here Queen G6 again threatening that
Queen in trade Queen D7 jumping in
Bishop F6 Queen takes B5 restoring the
material balance and this is the
position we have on the board important
that White's Queen can defend cover C2
now and rookie 8 the last move so can
Magnus milk this clear advantage or
small advantage that he thinks he has
was the game just fizzling out it's
level pawns and if E5 drops it's going
to be hard to imagine white winning can
I go F4
because why I don't think white should
be giving up the E5 Pawn or at least
this is this would be the first thing I
would be looking I see the bar does not
really agree with me so let's try and
figure out why probably Queen C2 can be
very powerful you can step forward and
go Queen D4 and then C5 would come if
white tries to cover everything The Rook
at the pawn then as you say Ivanka
pawns are Marching
and okay we have different
simplification yeah Queen C7 Queen E5
yeah Queen takes Pawn happened and white
has to say for King but can Magnus
really win this game look at his face
now slight frown there from uh the
Norwegian
looks like it's fizzling out this is not
just a queen trade threat but also B2 is
hit so if he wants to keep the game
going
wait how does he keep the game going
I don't think he can keep the Queens on
well what about he can attack The Rook
right green D7 yeah but then once you
step forward and attack the queen I
guess you keep that mirror dance going
on for a long long time
not really an active
move
yeah what do we think do we agree with
magnus's comments that he was better to
me it always seemed dynamically
complicated at the very minimum well I
think it was very tempting it was uh it
was very good for the eye that white has
all these very active pieces and the
black pieces were on the on the queen
side but sometimes you can overestimate
your position easily even you have such
an attack
and this can also mean if it's not true
that sometimes you don't have the most
objective senses during the game which
can be not a very good feeling if you
misjudge a position
yeah actually I must confess every time
I play a 2750 2800 player always in the
post-mortem afterwards they're like oh
of course this this and then I'm winning
this is this I was way better like how
could you play this I had a big
Advantage I go back and check and the
computer is like they were talking
nonsense the whole time but that kind of
uh sometimes a lack of objectivity is
good it kind of gives you confidence and
that's kind of if you exude that to your
opponents it uh it transmits and here we
go he keeps the Queens on
yes that's very clear I think that he
has to try to keep the Queens on and
post some problem for uh Anish but I
like very much the queen centralized on
E5 for black putting pressure on the B2
Pawn because it will be very hard to
save the pawn on B2 I believe
yeah it is difficult for instance if you
start chasing away the queen with the
Rook that's one idea that I had another
one was try to offer a queen trade
an issues of reaching for his Queen I
think on the camera he's hesitating here
11 minutes for Anish and this we should
not underestimate that Anish has less
than 12 minutes while Magnus had 32
minutes because the game can be long and
this is what I think Magnus will be
playing for absolutely from the
Practical aspect of the game
for sure and queen E6 is on the board
yeah you know what I was thinking about
this move but then I rejected it after I
publicly said it because you can go
Queen takes Queen
and then to grab that pawn on D5 but if
we can go into these lines then we can
see that probably after takes takes
Bishop D5 black is able to simplify the
position and the end will be three pawns
versus two if I'm correct of course Rook
D6 is not possible to Bishop E4 so black
they are exchanging Bishops rookie 2 and
after a rook B5 Rook C2 and black is
going to be pushing C3 yeah
just to show this type of endgame 3
versus 2 should be quite as
straightforward draw at this level white
simply cannot create a past Pawn without
exchanging everything off and Anish will
draw this one in his sleep so Magnus
once a bit more Queen E6
what do we think he won't take if he
wants to win
but how does he keep uh winning chances
does he just play Queen A7
keep the tension
Queen B5 maybe Quinn A7 I like if the
White Queen can come back to D4 but I'm
afraid from White perspective that black
is going to be chasing the White Queen
if uh I mean even now Queen E7 is
possible and after Queen D4 Queen E5 or
going back yeah that's also a great idea
yeah and here we might always see the
evaluation bar slightly on white side
but that's mainly because Ivanka as you
mentioned white can win a pawn and go
into this uh component game and that's
where computers kind of be truly trusted
that's just a dead draw even if white is
given a small Advantage there again
after Bishop takes Pawn that end game is
imminent yeah this is a big question how
Magnus can think of something Magic
to be able to play on this game without
simplification
kind of interesting
pursuing that Magnus
so optimistic that he kind of wants to
keep the game alive
is this in general a healthy attitude to
think the most of your position and then
just keep on trying or should you know
the bearing in mind that this is a long
grueling tournament should Magnus go you
know what I'm just going to accept that
the position is what it is it's a draw
it's fairly simplified
I think he cannot accept this because
it's around five so he desperately wants
to win a classical game and if he can
keep it without risking anything he has
to try every possible
opportunity to keep the game going
yeah and
I think there's minimal risk attached
here as well if it were maybe a more
complex position where playing on would
demands that you really burn your
Bridges then maybe Magnus would extend
his hand and say okay let's just settle
this in Armageddon but in such a complex
fight uh yeah in such an end game like
this yeah he can always bail out with
the drawer it feels like and then when
it comes to risk at what point like
roughly what kind of percentage in your
mind do you guys think
this is it okay we're talking about risk
talking about percentages we do have an
Armageddon game between nordebec Abdus
Turf and go cash and they are off
remember nordebec will start with 10
minutes on the clock good cash for just
seven minutes the players once they
reach past move 40 we will be getting a
one second increment and this is the
most important thing
cash has draw odds
and it's a quick start to this game it's
another Catalan just as we saw between
Magnus Carlson and Anish giri but a
totally different variation here black
is aiming to just trade everything off
in the center as quickly as possible and
go down to asymmetrical structure this
tends to favor white slight squared
Bishop but if black can solve his
problems concretely as good cash is kind
of banking on doing here then he'll be
very happy and okay look at this he's
getting ready to kick back the White
Queen he's getting ready to play B5
white can restore the balance but
Black's gaining some time
White's Queen is losing several Tempe
here absolutely Black Goes B5 Bishop B7
in a second will be on the board
looks totally fine to me it's a very
healthy position right for both sides
but no their back is under pressure
must win situation and it seems like
gokesh wants to play healthy and safe
yeah his position looks very healthy and
safe right now I don't see how white can
get active just by the fact that Abdus
tour of his pausing right now it means
that he is out of book or at least he's
not too familiar with the move orders
the ideas if I remember correctly maybe
he shouldn't have castled because now
black is able to kind of neutralize
white slight Square Bishop and if black
gets two more moves just gets castled
then black is extremely happy
and okay sliding with the Rook first
already Waits Queen is so uncomfortably
placed C2
yeah
black has a very nice development wow I
mean just taking a look at the database
here on just.com I can see that
the stats were very much in Black's
favor I was thinking it was like 60 was
a victory for black
and here
cash has simply found a nice home for
his Queen everything is perfectly placed
all he needs to do is just skedaddle
with the King to safety and
easy position
yeah super play and super speed from
kakash he's only used around 30 seconds
to get this to this point the time
deficit has halved it's only down to a
minute and a half difference and yeah
perfect position symmetrical not too
difficult no real calculation or tactics
to be seen
A4 he has to try something Abdus you
have to try to disbalance this position
before he wants to go A5 I believe and
go Knight A4 though I'm not sure the
White Knight will be very happy over
there on the rim
yup he has to go for it though that's uh
the key and I think we're headed down
that direction Judah
A5 here you simply have to kick back
that black queen have to do something
it's not fun for a while to move away
the knight from C3 because the bishop
can
show up on D5 Queen on B7 and the black
can have a very dominating position with
the bishop pair in the center I think we
might see that dominating position
anyway if as long as the black queen can
find a safe Square
and if I were black I would probably
tuck it in the corner I mean it looks a
bit strange but I was a little bit
afraid that if you put your queen on d8
that it might not be so comfortable
later on once the white Works
centralized at the same time after night
day for the A5 Pawn might be yes someday
a loss for white
yeah watch out for that pawn dropping
off the board and immediately after
Knight A4 right exactly nutbeck also has
uh the problem of this bishop D5 move
incoming hitting that white queen as you
said through that White Queen lacking
too many safe squares
looks great from good cash so far and
the White Knight forced back just to
keep the contact with the white Rook
component but that is depressing you
can't be happy when you have to go back
in such a position to the initial square
with your knight yeah and the cash just
costly the king to safety uh he has the
dream position well look what the
development Advantage for black look at
the Bishops the the nice The Rook on C8
and white has to restart his development
um whites lost so much time I think four
or five moves with White Queen and now
this White Knight has moved three times
black meanwhile has been very efficient
and everything perfect
at the same time sometimes you get a
very good position but you have to keep
going and probably white will be moving
away with his screen from B3 playing B3
Bishop B2 trying to locate his Knight to
C4 and somehow stabilize the position
but he goes Rook D1
is keeping things simple that's the
motto so far he just plants his Queen on
a very nice safe Square the other Black
Brook is getting ready to uh go to d8
everything harmonized everything
coordinated here Ken white develop with
his pieces ever you know one day Bishop
F2 is right there on the corner
oh Knight E1 good classical Catalan move
normally the White Knight wants to sit
on D3 but this time it just feels wrong
we see the question mark attachment
maybe bishop after which time what do
you think oh it's not gonna happen in
Armageddon though unless really invests
all his time to calculate it could be
strong though drew that maybe well I
don't know the white pieces are not
ready Bishop takes porn followed by a
queen check but not only Queen check
also in the Knight C5 is something to
look after you know because if you you
cannot go to E3 with the queen Knight G4
if you go to the C file Knight E4 check
can happen if you have to go to A2 then
not G4 and Knight E3 so something
but of course it's understandable
yeah I think uh something was tingling
there his instincts were on fire there
go cash but he had to be practical he's
only got four minutes he brings his
Knight into the center we see the Red
Cross there temporarily that was because
an opportunity was missed maybe it was
uh people takes F2 as Judith mentioned
but still a healthy position for black
yeah nice and safe as well and you were
right Judith that was the or golden
opportunity for good cash but he has a
very good position right now on the
board take a look at White's pieces
they're all on the back row
I think
it was a blunder by white because there
is no move protecting the F2 Square E2
Pawn cannot play E3 because F3 is under
attack
so
I should be three on the board this
structure is going to be destroyed now
of this tour of
cash can just capture this bishop and
white will not be loving any middle game
any end game with those doubled e-pawns
I mean how would you capture that Bishop
it's so tempting to go kind of go Knight
takes Bishop okay and it is on the board
I mean E4 okay hunt down the E3 Pawn I
like it
feeling so relaxed that he can get up
and check out the screen how close he is
to getting increment he's got four
minutes to make 17 moves before he gets
that luxury of one second but grabbing
the pawn
[Music]
free porn and big advantage
I'm not sure it's Abdul sotorov who's
gonna survive until move 40.
what he's fighting
and cash under four minutes whereas
Abdus has over five minutes and remember
the players are playing without
increment they will get just a one
second increment once they passed move
40 and there you see nice centralization
of the Rooks
beautiful
yeah he's even willing to give up two
Rooks for White Queen because White's
remaining Rooks and this is going to
happen whites Brooks will not be
coordinated White's Pawn structure is in
ruins the black queen and black Bishop
looks too active here for white to ever
hope for equality let alone an advantage
well very bad piece play for white apart
from the fact that uh queen and the poem
versus two Rooks is just fine special
even and there is no activity we need
two on the board I mean attacking the
rook and the B2 Pawn
how can you hold on a blacks Plex
position is a simply overwhelming
yeah I don't think you can hold on he
went for an imbalance here abductor if
you had to try something hence the queen
for two Rook decision but black simply
coming in and this one could be over any
minute could cash too good
yeah the white Rook had to run away if
it had gone to B3 it would have been
trapped immediately so Rook to D7
hunting for Council please take some B2
I believe
attacking The Rook
extra material go for it and he does
yep that ball disappears
and whites Brook moves but you can move
the F7 Pawn you can defend the F7 Pawn
black people is going to decide the game
well the bishop is extremely powerful
yeah far superior to the White Knight
I think this was just decided in the
opening right not the back's never been
in the game never had the fight even
B3 it doesn't even bother to defend the
F Pawn I mean what can you suggest for
not a big except for grab that pawn and
hope for the best
well I believe uh Queen C3 is going to
be on the board or queen C2 first enough
to root D7 then Queen C3 and the pawn
will be pushed
again feeling confident gets up to check
how many moves have been made not abec
either he goes extremely passive to stop
the B Pawn where he'll be beaten slowly
but surely or he goes active as you say
true that tries to go for the black king
with the two Rooks on the seventh rank
but that's easily defended that's easily
rebuffed
I think he's gonna go okay he just
slides across
B2
rugby seven
he's holding up temporarily
how does black break through
okay lining up against the white E2 pawn
and the worst thing is that of course
White's in a must win situation and all
this so you can't just simply bail out
with Rook F2 Queen D1 there you go
repeating the position yes because a
draw is as good as a loss for an order
back
yeah nothing to do you're pretty much
tied up here you're bound hand and foot
you cannot move
black people aren't too strong I think
you'll bail out Rook F2
and we'll see that handshake
Bishop E3 is actually such a deadly
threat
it's all falling apart maybe he can try
and hold on with Rook B3 but that's not
going to solve anything
I think he may try to play Rook B8 let's
say
and if Bishop A3 takes the X to go Rook
F2 not Rook F2 King G2
and somehow try to win the B2 Pawn
yeah it feels like black will have a
Perpetual check with the queen
either way also breaking news we will
have another Armageddon because Magnus
Carlsen has just drawn against Anish
Gary we'll go to that one shortly
the Armageddon due to start in 20
minutes
here we see them uh Magnus head in hands
for a second there Anish explaining
something or discussing something
with the Norwegian
but let's stick with this game abdusator
of just deciding how to fall on his
sword here nothing to be done no defense
Rock back to B3 oh no but the queen will
come to C2
well it's just a repetition right
between C2 Ruby seven going back Queen
E2 and they're starting to repeat the
position that we see kakash is called
the Arbiter he's about to play the move
Queen E2 that will be the third time
that position is repeated and handshake
it is a draw kukash takes the points oh
walking away with one and a half points
whereas Nordy back gets just one point
oh
what is happening here
just to clarifying the result this
individual game was a draw but of course
a draw suits Black in the Armageddon
and uh here we've seen yeah good cash
after that really exemplary display
impressive stuff taking the point but it
was very interesting that it was it was
an extremely professional way of making
a draw and he had a great opportunity he
was kind of winning in one moment and
after that he had a great position
almost winning yeah and at the end he
was even wanted to claim the draw that
it's a three repetition so it was like
really on his mind that draw wins yes
and uh well that was a great result but
we also checking out those the bird's
eye view we can see that Fabiano is in
serious trouble against Shaq mamajarov
is going to win it
yeah potentially groundbreaking result
here a huge huge drama on the board we
also saw Hikaru Nakamura there that game
is getting very tense he car returning
things in his favor but yeah Mama jarov
he's about to break Fabiano's heart it
looks like just a pawn Advantage here
for black queens are guaranteed to come
off the board on the next move and
blacks extra three versus one majority
on the queen side is going to decide
this one the black apron we called it
earlier yeah but it does look like a
Fabiana blundered in the previous move
yeah and he's been under time pressure
we should clarify Fabiano's only got six
minutes they're still not at move 40 but
yeah difficult position and a mistake
from him MVC and go into the last few
moves what has happened to him
yep let's quickly jump in uh Fabiano
head in hands he's got to move he's got
to move quickly he's got to think
quickly we last left this at Rook takes
E6 a really classy move banking on back
rank traps uh from manager of here the
bishop drops back with a check we saw
the black king hide in the corner after
Rook to D1 keeping the Rooks on the
board Queen D6 and looks like my major
have just come kind of controlled things
really nicely here H4 and a few moves
down the line the back rank for white
proved to be the weakness Queen E5 and I
think the slip was here
uh Queen to D3 we see brandished with a
question mark I'm not sure what he
should have done well I I just had the
computer open and it said King H2 only
move to save and game
and then Rook takes Bishop Rachel check
if with drug G8 it it is after King H2
um if you were to grab the bishop then
you would play
I don't know maybe the computer's
uncertain he goes rookie eight
wow Rook 68 I think your right shoe that
Rook takes and just a check and maybe
there's no way to hide for this black
king
even the evaluation bar here we see it's
like up and down and changing its mind
is so complicated this one is a
difficult one to spot for Fabiano uh we
can forgive him for missing this but it
will cost him the point instead he
passively defended his Bishop what could
be more logical and queen to be one is
the killer blow now there's no way to
keep the queen intact with her Bishop uh
therefore the Queen's coming off the
board
so confident he steps up
looks like Fabby crashing to defeat with
the white pieces the tournament being
thrown wide open
dramatic times in Norway chess
and there we see Fabiano in deep
concentration
fighting hard to find a way to survive
and all the me and in the while
there is simply the problem of the clock
remember Fabiano will be only getting a
10 second increment once they pass move
40.
yeah move 40 still a few turns away so
four minutes left on the clock to pick
apart the ruins of this position to even
find a way to keep the game alive a
queen trade and it's going to be slow
but uh inevitable he will crash defeat
here yeah and uh in the meantime we are
joined in the studio by kukash who just
to be defeated nordebec in an Armageddon
game so talk us through that match
um yeah today I in general I think I've
played quite well in the classical game
I faced a surprise this H3 move which I
was not yeah which I was not aware of
but I guess it was not a very strong
idea there were a few ways and I thought
what I did was maybe uh slightly worse
but uh it was quite safe and it avoided
his prep so
uh I was quite happy with my reaction
and uh and then maybe I had a slight
chance with the
Queen C7 instead of Queen C5 uh I rushed
a bit there but still okay it should it
should be a draw with the decent play
yeah
so I sorry were you checking B4 at that
point uh after between C5 if B4 would be
played yeah Queen C5 I wanted to provoke
B4 so that like
I mean there are more tricks with uh
with the Knight on C3 kind of hanging so
I thought uh provoking B4 was clever but
I just completely missed that he has
Knight E2
and I was thinking of sorry if B4 you go
back to C7 yeah and then if white goes
King B2 and Rook D3 Queen D2 as a plan
yeah uh maybe bishop uh
C6 or C8 and or maybe B4 Queen C7 Rook
D3
um we thought that maybe B4 can be a
plus for for white okay at first also we
thought that you want to provoke it and
it weakens the white structure the king
will be kind of safe on B2 yeah could I
uh maybe go B4 Queen E5
yeah anyway Rook D3 let's say trip ship
C6 windy too ah so this is the plan yeah
because somehow the queen on D2 I liked
very much the D file and also covering
the F4 yeah also F4 is a kind of thread
maybe you should have should have done
that yeah I realized that Queen CIFA is
anyways not a very good move
but yeah before yeah I underestimated
before and when you rejected this
repetition of moves did you reject it
because you wanted to play for a win you
just have a principle not to make
repetition of moves or What feelings you
had the I was I was thinking like
okay he was pressing for a win all along
and
um it would be kind of psychologically
hard for him to you know sit and find
and draw and uh okay I also was ahead on
time and my question I don't I didn't
think it was like any risk for me so
I thought I'll play a few more anyways
mostly beard but then I'll just try for
a few moves and uh obviously you went
into Armageddon where you had a very
smooth game I mean do you find it easy
to adjust when playing a classical game
and then moving on to a faster time
control
um
I think in general uh before the
classical game you have a brief idea of
what you're going to do if it goes to
Armageddon
and I've already played two armageddons
in this tournament so I was kind of
ready
for it and okay
it if you get uh such a position against
in after the opening I think you know
you're generally happy he just uh didn't
know the line and I think uh already
Castle was uh was dubious and after A6
if I'm just
uh maybe even better for black so yeah
and uh yesterday of course you had a
spectacular Armageddon game against
Magnus Carlsen where they're you're
moving quickly peace imbalances I mean
what were your thoughts on that game
of course it was uh it was a crazy game
classical I was just uh after I survived
it it was like I I felt like I just
escaped hell after that and uh yeah I
was just super happy to get to
Armageddon and
uh I was actually very relaxed during
the game I just thought I'll just throw
my pieces and see what happens and
I think I've found some nice ideas but
uh
he defended very well and in the end
after Queen E3 had E6 but okay this with
five seconds anything can happen so
yeah it was a very uh nice experience
against Madness yeah and uh how are you
finding Stavanger and Norway chess in
general
uh this is my second time uh I I was
here in 21 when we we met for the first
time I think that was a honor for me and
I played in the open section and uh
yeah this place is very nice we are
going for walks with my trainer and it's
uh yeah it's great to me
and you mentioned you're going on walks
with the trainer enjoying the nature do
you have any other pre-game rituals
um not really just in general I would
prepare for a while rest for a while
yeah and you've been playing a lot of
tournaments recently I think this is
your fifth tournament in a row
uh not really uh is it more I
I played the Sharjah Masters before this
even yeah
and before Sharjah had a one week break
at home okay yeah not much but it was
not then not continuously so
and uh well looking at the games do you
have any thoughts do you think uh
Fabiana caruana will be able to survive
this against the chakra
and uh then I'm gonna
steal your thoughts on uh hikaru's game
against Arya okay I if I be skimmed I
see the computer is giving winning for
black and
okay there should be a way to escape the
future do you always believe the engines
uh not really but I guess this position
it has to be accurate because the King
goes to E5 I think and
just king of fight queen of trekking if
I just King runs all the way to the
Queen's head
how much are you following the other
games during your game
during when I'm playing yes because you
know Hikaru he is usually going into the
confessional booth and he's like taking
over our job and he's explaining to
everybody what's going on not only in
his game but also all the other games
how much are you following the other
games
um I do take walks I do look at the
digital screen but
I should say I don't follow others games
very closely unless I mean I remember
there was this
magnificent and I was like I think it
was my move but I just could not stop
watching that game
but in general I'm uh I don't look at
other games a lot
and have you been tempted to go into the
confessional booth and share with us
your thoughts I should at some point
probably but till now I hadn't uh hadn't
thought about it wow yeah
and uh and I'd also like to
just get your opinion on this very tense
game between
um Hikaru Nakamura and Ari antari and
just to mention the game between Wesley
so and Ali Reza farusha did end in a
draw so we are going to see our third
Armageddon of the day
and it looks very scary you know black
has some pawns on B3 and B4
what's happening
maybe bishop B6 uh
uh the mission was not written
maybe next white will just go King E2
and uh black has to protect the F5 pawn
and then he can
move the D1 rook and start collecting
some pawns on the queen side yeah
it does look quite good for it it looks
good for white so good for Hikaru and
also the evaluation bar does confirm
that yeah I did look at it first
I didn't see it my eyesight's not that
great
so yeah thank you very much kikash for
joining us in the studio and good luck
in tomorrow's game thank you
some more Armageddon games in store and
there we can see Hikaru enjoying his
position against Aryan Atari who
celebrates his 24th birthday today
I think this is not exactly what he had
in mind and his face expression also
tells it all
the basically he gave up already this
position this is what I'm reading
from his face and something went really
very wrong in the last several moves
since we've seen this yeah should we do
a quick action replay yeah just let's
see how
Nakamura
laid it out
so that he has a winning position or
much much better for sure how did Naka
work his magic we left the game after
Queen G6 Pawn to C3 we expected all of
this a capture capture and rather than
retreating to E6 where we thought aryam
would be doing okay uh with his Knight
he jumped forward to B3 and maybe this
was the start of where things got a bit
shaky suddenly an imbalance incoming
Knight E4 the Queens disappeared and we
saw the first mistake from uh Aryan
objectively given a question mark by the
computer C5 this allowed a trade and
before the black Bishop is allowed to
open up again a really classy
instructive move here at C4 fixing the
black Pawn on C5 fixing the black Bishop
therefore on a blunted diagonal and uh
we saw things only turn in White's favor
here I think Ariana already struggling
to find counter play gave up his Pawn
with H5 in order to push his Pawn to F5
but after this gift was gratefully
accepted we saw the White Knight found a
nice safe square and after F4 Hikaru
he's ready to trade things off ready to
Simply by a takes B4 on the board
I think the plan here after C takes B is
simply to remove the knight from uh
sorry the Bishop from the board trade
things off and here sooner or later
these Central white connected past pawns
will decide the game white support up
not too much to worry about here
yeah it seems to be pretty sad from the
black side here black would have uh well
Double B Pawn which is not helping much
yes indeed
rough birthday I know I was thinking
about it I mean it was just one
it felt like a small mistake but in the
end it was such a positional error
that I just turned it around
and that's how Nakamura collects a lot
of his points these days he just keeps
the tension keeps the tension keeps the
tension waits for his opponents to slip
up uh even if it's a small strategic
mistake but he's so good at taking his
chances and especially if he gets a
risk-free position he very rarely lets
it slip so yeah looks like birthday
disappointment for tarry it seems to be
a birthday curse just top players they
seem to struggle I've done it myself
lost on my birthday me too don't worry
you're not alone
something in the air it's just hard to
focus I guess when there's so much going
on never played on my birthday you're
lucky Ivanka trust me even uh olympias
you never had your birthday no it's in
June June is like Prime Time holiday
season no one's having any good
tournaments then ivanka's birthday is
next week everyone so get ready to
congratulate her
the day after this finishes so yeah
we want birthday song messages and
yeah lots of Celebration there but
unfortunately for today Harry and Harry
is going to go home empty-handed nothing
much to discuss in this position there's
various ways you can kind of simplify
the tension but you see on the body
language
okay he gives off a second Pawn just
moves this bishop keeps at least that
imbalance of Knight versus Bishop for
life
but you get the impression this won't
save him
White's got to be two pawns up in the
ensuing end game
okay should we pause this one and see
what's going on it looks like Fabby has
been chasing Black's King around the
board
and it seems like Mom and jarov is
hesitating how to finish off the game
because he has a huge Advantage
advantage and material
and maybe we get a look
concretely what is happening there are
Czech was giving all the way by Fabiano
so the King was chased from H6 all the
way to C7
Fabi with no time on the clock there we
can see moving his King
to G1 to defend the bishop
he made that move with two seconds left
on his clock but he's walking into a pin
this white Bishop is doomed either now
or even over the next few moves nothing
to do and fabi's just prolonging the
inevitable here the black king is going
to be super safe later on it's going to
hide on a square like B6 hero would just
be playing a move like Queen D4
centralization and black boy Queen E2
yeah I was thinking the same grab what
about grabbing material with Queen D3
24 23 Queen E2 this Bishop's dude but
also A4 is not such a bad option
oh
they're mean here aren't we looking at
all the ways for white twin and he does
go for Queen D3
what's gonna happen next Fabiano less
than 10 seconds
it's I think he'll throw in a spike
check or it's going to be resigns
oh when he made that move with just a
couple seconds left again Fabi and uh
just while we wait for that result to
tick in it's incoming any moment now we
see the Armageddon game again with
Magnus Carson and Anish Gary Magnus with
white will we see a repeat of the
earlier clash in the Catalan
quick moves to start with no this time
it's the nimzo Indian and the queen C2
variation where white gets the bishop
pair but White's Queen forced around the
board a bit and very classical yeah the
Eric was stopped Judith
yeah and the Knight coming in to attack
the queen and now the pawn structure has
stabilized in the center
Magnus has employed this variation
recently if I recall uh this line with C
takes D5 didn't have a great reputation
uh sorry Magnus trading pawns a couple
of moves ago it didn't have a great
reputation for a long time but suddenly
it's come back into fashion and I
remember some clashes between Fabiano
and Hikaru in this line gets very very
sharp Magnus clearly has done its
homework and a niche pausing
can't afford too many long thinks in an
Armageddon he's been caught unawares by
this opening choice and in the meanwhile
Fabiano has resigned Shakura does walk
away with three points
very important three points for Sakura
who was at the tail end of the
tournament and now as you said you did
anything can happen
it's getting close yeah suddenly
Fabiano's four-point lead in the
tournament might be cut down to one
point if Hikaru wins his classical
encounter anything can happen now indeed
and meanwhile something should happen
for initial any move is better than none
at this point he spent one minute over
one minute on this move at the same time
he wants to decide how to react on that
because after that he's going to be
probably pretty fast the next moves
sacrifice the pawn for compensation
let's see whether is he going to be
really having enough compensation in
this game
yeah and Magnus knows what to do of
course he did not hesitate at all he
grabbed the pawn and here black has to
decide how to compensate you need to be
quick you need to get pieces into the
game while all of White's King side
pieces are still asleep and of course
Queen exchange and unleash his gamers in
so many other games this is what we've
seen but I think this is the good move
and then play Rook C2 looking for
counter chance
and the compensation will be
pretty obvious but I'm sure that black
will have to make accurate moves yeah
two options for white either you keep
your Bishop alive or you save a bit of
time by capturing this Black Knight you
give yourself a Tempo but on the
downside you don't have the bishop
person Magnus Retreats back to F4 and so
yeah that Rook is going to land any
moment now there we go Rook to C2
how does white affect those black pieces
the Black Knight in the center can be
kicked away question mark though
attached to that move
because Magnus does immediately play F3
Knight has to go back to F6 yeah that's
kind of for painful news
yeah I wonder whether Anish should have
finessed this maybe played a move like
G5 first maybe G4 is coming I remember
this because the black Bishop can go to
G6 because Rook C1 immediately with some
tactics and if the bishop has to move
back to E6 then Rook B1 will be possible
and then E3 Bishop D3 comes yeah slowly
but surely white can affect those black
pieces out of his half he's already
kicked back the Knight and Bishop I love
your move dude at The Rook B1 Magnus
loves it too I think he's just played it
and two moves before Magnus establishes
full stability E3 Bishop D3 and then
it's just an extra pawn and Bishop well
this is absolutely home prep for Magnus
I believe this was a great trap it was a
trap and it had been played before and
it was just a careless moment from Anish
and once again Magnus being very Wily
with his opening choices and now the
bishop does come to D3 The Rook is
kicked back
but as David and Judah have been
highlighting white is simply material up
with a great position and to boot
and he looks away from the board and
disgust not liking what he's done even
if Magnus didn't have the extra E3 Pawn
I think he would still be a big favorite
in this game just because white has full
control Bishop pair why just needs to
get it exactly that things are not going
well to have such a position against
Magnus spawned down Bishop pair he's
going to be playing King F2 I think
simply and eventually E4
I heard some bad experience against
Magnus back in Vikings saying some
similar I have a phone up but just the
position was
was not good
yeah and that's the thing drew that you
mentioned the strategy getting the
Queen's off as early as possible it
works against most people but against
Magnus uh maybe one of the exceptions uh
he loves these types of positions as
well uh when there's no risk no
complications just slowly improving the
extra Pawn just a bonus
extra three minutes also can't hurt for
Magnus Carlson I think it would be a
bigger shock at the tournament if Magnus
didn't convert the advantage from here
Gary looking away again he's got his
pieces of nice squares but they can go
no further yeah see how annoyed he is
with the position having gone the board
yeah and it's maybe a new experience for
Gary it's rare to see him kind of lost
out of the opening ever let alone uh
kind of after 15 20 moves
disaster and Magnus just taking his time
he'll improve the white Rook on each one
he'll start playing moves like H4
first he lines up
at some point he might play A4 B3 kick
away the black knight from C4
and black will have no more counter play
well why
sorry black will have some tiny hope in
the fact that Magnus is in a must-win
situation so if Magnus for some reason
squanders away his Advantage then okay
it's okay
but uh okay well a niche cementing his
Knight on C4
this is good strategy it's very
difficult to recommend anything for a
niche other than just to make his pieces
better and just
hope for the best I realize that hope is
not a great plan in general I hope that
kills you
but still
it's something yeah and some small
threats Knight takes B2 occasionally in
the air uh the Black Knight hopping out
the way but yeah it's it's the type of
position you just have to play annoying
moves that's what I try and do in Blitz
when things are going wrong but your
opponent doesn't have to be too much
time just confuse them or at least block
their plans block their plans block
their plans until they get frustrated
that's the only hope now you can see on
the camera I've never seen a niche this
devastated this annoyed at himself
before yeah because it's just after 10
moves or so it was obvious that he is
going to go behind the material he's
picked up the bishop up
fumbling the pieces Anish
we see a trade there white tonight has a
beautiful Square on C3 now
what is magnus's plan he just bypasses
the pawn
wow trying to create a past B Pawn if
black doesn't capture on passant now
then white tonight will sit on C3
forever with a nice blockade we see a
trade opposite color Bishops at least
but small solace
still upon up
okay everything coming off the board
well Mike Magnus certainly has his eyes
on the B6 Pawn
it's now time for the bishop to get into
the game perhaps Retreat to D7 support
the advance of the B Pawn but nope he's
pushed his H Pawn
but they always say when you're
struggling exchange pieces exchange
pawns sorry the problem for a niche is
that he's simply lost another Pawn now
if if the Black Knight takes back on H5
white has Bishop C7 and the black B Pawn
drops the second issue is even if he
goes defensive and defenses b-born he's
going to be tied up paralyzed
immobilized forever this one's over
see sad move King H7 and the E4 will be
coming yeah
Magnus first improving his King why not
turns the pawn no no no no and uh that's
it anisha's had enough and Magnus takes
the Armageddon point and therefore picks
up one and a half points for a niche it
is a bad day at the office and he loses
yeah magnus's fourth Armageddon win out
of five rounds so far but still not
enough to uh get close to the lead
Magnus needs to up his gaming classical
but looking smooth so far in the
Armageddon and uh talking about the
classical games there has been another
decisive result Hikaru Nakamura as
expected did defeat Aryan tari and there
you can see the two analyzing and this
is a super important three points for
Hikaru that takes him one point behind
Fabiano in the standings and there is
absolutely everything to play for in the
remaining four rounds of Norwich s
yeah the results piling in there thick
and fast and uh yeah sad day for Aryan
but in the end nakamura's nurse just
held
and nice to see the players discussing
the game afterwards just to show an
action replay of how that game ended
this was the final position we'll
investigate in a second let's go back
and play through the final few moves we
left it after Bishop to B6 here
desperate attempt from ariantari and uh
here Hikaru simply captured upon
discover check against the white king
this was met by an advanced King F3 and
nice control here from Hikaru just D4
pushing forward and it was the two white
Central pawns that did the business here
eventually C5 did arrive nice trick here
don't take the Rook because your Rook
would fall but after C5 a last tactic to
finish the game Knight D6 and C takes B6
this is winning because for example
after Rook takes Rook B7 and no way to
prevent promotion a queen would appear
next turn beautiful technique and all
three points for Hikaru Nakamura
absolutely and after all that action I
think it's the perfect time to take a
breather and we're gonna be seeing you
shortly after the break
oh he's I was here I was I was lost oh
okay well hey
let's go oh no I think I should have
just done that sure I got
we beat it let's go no 15 unreal no
first try eight in a row nine in a row
baby let's go
let's go let's go I gotta oh cool I got
a little achievement thing I honestly
really enjoyed that that was really cool
become a chess.com Community streamer at
go.chess.com start streaming
remember that day was Unreal I
definitely felt like I was walking on
air
yeah it was like such a beautiful
feeling because I won the the first
championship that was actually combining
women and men into the same section so
in addition to winning the title and the
money which I really needed it was like
something like 9 500 but I was like a
college student at the time and like
literally that was like all the money I
had in my bank account after cashing
that check so that was really cool and
then also I kind of I have Norm so it
was like a little bit of everything
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
straight into the action because it is
Armageddon time between Wesley so and
alireza farouza let's ignite that chess
fire Wesley in now in a must win
situation he will start with 10 minutes
on the clock alif alireza only has seven
minutes but alireza does get those draw
odds and of course there you can see it
after move 40 the players will get a
tiny one second increment
and we have started with the Roy Lopez
the Spanish opening met by the Berlin
defense from alarisa but it's the ante
Berlin so all the pieces still on the
board from Wesley good choice here
Judith
already it's such an early stages
regular move nowadays it's it's known
but it's rare as you say I think players
have started getting get desperate
simply against the Berlin and Bishop G5
started appearing everywhere we've seen
it in the Italian game multiple times
early Bishop G5 and uh for Asia may be
influenced by having those draw odds
retreating with blacks Bishop back to E7
Rock Solid I find it interesting that
before black is playing D6 it is an
option for black to go Bishop E7 back
right so it it gives a different game
for later because G5 will be very simple
if black wants to play it but probably
he will not want to play it he just
wants to go D6 maybe Knight H5 at some
point because Safety First and playing
for a draw which gives a victory for
black so probably that's the AIM or
ferozan yeah Rock Solid chest so far
from black and the question is when
Wesley will try and open the center he
goes for it immediately while the black
king is still stuck in the middle before
Black's castled makes sense I guess now
the Dilemma for farouza is whether he
can Castle or not can he get away with
that you don't really want to capture on
D4 you'll always have small disadvantage
uh so okay he actually backs up his
Knight on C6 blocks the PIN
solid solid position and White's Bishop
on H4 doesn't make a great impression
even if black has lost a Tempo with his
dark squared Bishop yeah it's kind of a
very interesting position
because the bishop H3 usually is not
there in this kind of position right and
the Stein is there something the
bishop's still has C1 yeah
it doesn't really help unless you can
put extra pressure on black Central Pawn
from G3
maybe that's one of the ideas from
Wesley I'm expecting first you have to
do some calculation often white does
threaten to take on C6 and then take on
E5 so farouzia does clarify the center
and what will Wesley go for maybe he
just wants to simplify everything and
after an id4 he also wants to exchange
that one
before
just as many pieces off the board as
possible
you're a prophet Judith everything
flying off Knight Squad Bishops as well
or keep those for now
but uh I mean is this enough to press
black
is I mean the only advantage that white
has is that Black's Bishop is worse than
White's
but both of them are hardly useful
pieces I would say yeah this Pawn
structure often favors white when there
are more pieces on the board because
then black is extremely uh cramped and
yeah right now as you say Ivanka doesn't
feel like too much of an advantage black
still has to be a bit careful and wary
of Pawn breaks like E5 might come at
some point but if you can step out of
anything concrete you should be doing
okay no weaknesses in the black Camp
yeah basically that's the only big issue
what can happen to Black if white can
play E5 in a good moment
I'm not sure it is the case here because
after E5 black would capture it and go
Queen C8 for example
just take and move out the way
symmetrical Pawn structure
so is E5 a threat that's the big
question and he gets out of the way uh
really nice preemptive move there
prophylaxis with Queen C8 I think it
would be time to play E5 eventually I
don't know if after E5 takes Rook takes
Rook d8 might be the good simplification
for black
yeah that can take and play Rook d8
sometimes the black queen is coming out
to G4 as well I have to be careful of
that one is she coming out now
she absolutely isn't oh she is now I was
gonna say no okay the bishop actually
drops back
and I guess Ali Reza just has a very
nice plan of centralizing the Rook he
defends the sea
C7 Pawn what did prophylactical move
playing Rook C8 for a later stage if
white plays E5 takes Bishop E5 then the
C7 Pawn is already protected
and H3 kicking back the black queen to a
slightly clumsy Square on G6 it could be
very active here but also it could get
caught offside
there's some plan to play Knight H5 and
bring the bishop to F6 and E5
activate the bishop enter yeah can't
hurt and I wouldn't be surprised if the
prophylaxis continues if White's Bishop
gets out the way with Bishop H2 uh just
getting out of the way of any Knight H5
hits so that white will have an extra
Tempo later on depending on what black
does
yeah and Bishop H2 is on the board and
flex Bishop drops back is white going to
be playing rookie 3 and attack on
oh here it comes F Pawn steps forward
yeah that plan's still in the other
watch out for it later the white rook's
swinging towards the black king but this
was another plus behind dropping back
the white Bishop the F4 no longer tied
down to that piece and this is why I
didn't like the black queen on G6 yes
that queen I'm also kind of has it but
wait one second are there some tactical
ideas in the air after all the king and
queen are standing on the same diagonal
yeah if Black's Bishop could leap over
somehow okay wow you called it I was
gonna say if the black Bishop could have
leapt over to C5 there would have been a
nasty skewer so as you mentioned get out
of the way of any tactics working on H1
super safe oh I like White's position I
think there is some pressure what Wesley
so built up yeah if black could just
trade off one more set of pieces if
that's Queens there we go whether it's
Knights Bishops then black should be
fine the space issue won't matter but at
the moment it feels really really
suffocating for black uh just struggling
for squares and queen F6 I think Wesley
has to avoid this trade
Queen C4 Queen I don't know F2 just any
safe Square just do not get greedy and
go Pawn hunting and put your queen on A7
that is a recipe for disaster and resist
the push the pawn yes and uh well that
seemed like it was a an advancement in
Wesley's favor the queen slides over to
attack C2 but Queen F2 and you cannot
grab the pawn on E5 because the Knight
on D7 is just loose now F5 is a thread
and if black plays Queen F5 I think G4
is coming
Ivanka will be very happy to see that G4
F5 E6 they have a lunch begins
and yeah how does black stop this it's
not so easy F5 is a monster threat you
think
well maybe black will have to play F5
maybe black has to block this indeed
that's committal you weaken the black
king but at the same it's Master H2
Bishop will be there for quite some time
and F5 is on the board yeah
yes it is on the board and alireza
farouza just over three and a half
minutes left remember there is no
increment for the players until they
reach past move 40 and then they get a
tiny one second increment not a lot
there we see the players in Focus what
do you think about playing G4 anyway
yeah makes a lot of sense you could
maybe prepare it with Queen F3 as well
but G4
no oh I'm not sure about that decision
it feels like this might just lead to
more piece exchangers but he wants F5 on
this next move I like to shoot it just
go all in it's Armageddon scare the
opponent but hesitation for farisha this
is Queen to F7 and then
takes it back
why not Queen F7 he's committed now
he's touched his Queen he has to move
his Queen and she does drop back to F7
Queen F3 I'm just looking at Targets
here the White Queen improves hitting B7
on the board maybe just Rook takes
yeah makes sense to get something uh get
those trades going
farooja down now to under three minutes
needs to speed up
it's been a slow start to this
Armageddon game C6 eventually on the
board relying on tactics which means
that probably after Rook takes E8 he
wants to take back with the Knight on E8
possibly because if Rook takes then I
think Bishop D6 takes the X check on E1
King H2 and after Queen C7 uh Queen G3
Queen G3 white is just defending
everything in town yes because it's
hitting the Rook on E1
still a bit precarious there Rook C1
white is really stuck in that final
position
well okay we're gonna see it no chance
for Russia was ever gonna take back with
the Knight he's an active player and
we're gonna see this variation it's on
the board I don't like this for Wesley
one bit it feels like you've won a pawn
yes but you've lost all coordination and
we're going to see this line
queen of G3 defending White's attacking
blackstroke but now the black Rook just
moves oh and he wants some tricks if
let's say I thought Rook C1 Rook D2 then
Knight G4 and Rook H1
wow yeah
tricks all over the Border really nice
tactics
yeah if the white Rook moves to the
wrong Square then Rook H1 check as udit
mentioned and so probably white should
be playing Rook D3 and then after Queen
exchange taking with the King Rook F5
giving a check on the drug B8 trying
something but I don't see anything
better for white and we have to remember
Wesley is in a must win situation so he
has to maximize the opportunities in the
position by simply maintaining the
pieces and he does drop that Rook to D3
you called it Judith it's happening
Queens are off the board for Asia is
going to win his Pawn back symmetrical
structure but white King's slightly
closer to the middle and okay he has to
go behind he has to go Pawn hunting with
white
two or three moves and black is fully
fine so okay Rook B8 on the board the
only way to cause some trouble I have
Rook B6 but I would be very surprised if
alireza cannot hold the game
but uh moose you do have some some
Advantage here for instance after B5 you
can lock the pawns with A5 and then try
to get something there but okay alireza
gives a check this is a much better
solution because when the king moves
back then Rook F7 just defends the pawn
though after that route Knight E4 is
possible because King G4 would be a
mistake here because G6 not G6 Rook F4
Rook F4 and G6 sorry sorry was he
thinking about he surely has to go back
walking forward will get you checkmated
H4 is still an option but
probably not a very advisable one oh
he's playing with fire here Wesley oh he
moves it and after Rook G5
oh maybe he wants a G4 though yeah okay
the white king not getting mated but
it's living on the edge literally there
on H4 Knight F4 and yeah Black's going
Pawn hunting
no do you have to move your king back do
you have to repeat the position once
feels like you might live to regret it
if you do not come back with the white
King right now
but black has Rook F7 if you want black
can Retreat and just hold everything
defend everything maybe he's got plans
of playing G4 although that is
[Music]
scary it could well happen Ivanka and
look at the clocks they're almost
balanced now Wesley's time advantages
disappeared it's only 20 seconds in it
can he hold his nerve the players are
soon getting that valuable Priceless one
second increment
and he gambles well he has to roll the
dice and go for it and there we see
alireza grab a pawn the king steps back
and now the Knight attacks the sea to
pawn actually it was a must this was the
only chance in a must win situation to
take the pawn correct
yeah and he's banking everything on
White's A4 poor Knights are notoriously
bad against these uh Rooks pawns but the
problem is is there a force drawn out
going for Czech for Russia he's just
trying to force the white king back to
worst squares
very nice move very logical move he
might go after pawns later but only once
the white king is sidelined
beautiful played by black the rook and
Knight combining against the white king
and look at it falls back to G1 now the
black Rook can go Pawn hunting if it
wants give a couple of checks that's
what will be the case Wesley shook his
head there on the camera
he knows that black should draw this
with best play
what's he going to do is he going to
give a check with the Black Knight
faruga a bit nervous hesitating check
check and take
yeah
activating The Rook when in doubt get
the Rook behind black is opponent for a
moment
but uh White is banking all their hopes
on the a pawn which will be a passer
yeah it feels like white has to activate
the king sooner or later to try and
start a race
but Black's got everything under control
how to even test the opponent here
Knight to C4 is a threat Black's Knight
can go to the queen side go start
crafting pawns as well and uh look at
the clock time as well Wesley also
barely a Time advantage over alireza and
he grabs a c pawn and he looks up at the
sky and is like okay he's in trouble
this is such a difficult position to win
now he was looking up for inspiration
looking up maybe asking the chest God to
shine on him to smile because A5
clamping down nice move from Russia
under control for black
this one looks like it should fizzle out
towards a drawer one minute each now
Wesley you can see he doesn't have the
conviction behind his moves anymore
black is better because taking on B2 and
after Rook A5 Rook B3
and then if you move the Knight Knight
C4 discovered check or Rook C5 Knight D1
yeah he's going for something similar
wow he's forcing Knights off the board
the Black Knight is poisoned because
White's Rook would fall to the black
Rook if it was captured on D1
Wesley doesn't have too much to do he
has to grab the a pawn and start playing
as quickly as possible but I mean this
is Mission Impossible here to win this
the game is fast going into a draw and
there he grabs the a pawn simply Knight
takes Knight
no way no hope
will go behind sooner or later he'll go
behind the white a pawn tying down
White's rook and the white king too far
away to help
yeah Black's two versus one majority on
the king side will soon start to be
pushed as well this one Elementary time
but this I think he's going to be
agreeing to intro there is not much to
play for check if he goes out even that
home will be taken so there is zero
practical chance
and he's shaking his head
yeah and I think he's offering that draw
now there you go handshake and Ali Reza
wins the Armageddon game and gets one
and a half points and there with a shake
of his head a disappointed Wesley leaves
the board
oh
Armageddon games are exciting they're
keeping us on tender hooks for the whole
day and there we can see the auditorium
where the players are leaving and so are
the spectators
and of course that means we've had yet
another dramatic day of Chess this was a
real dramatic day it was indeed a very
dramatic from many aspects and for quite
a few players today yeah absolutely and
we've seen a lot of unexpected results
and the big one was actually
Fabiana carrona losing with the white
pieces against Shakura mamajarov in
their classical encounter and Hikaru
Nakamura also winning in the classical
game against Aryan Atari and of course
chakra are getting a momentous Victory
and of course let's have a few words
with him
a proper Sac attack today what do you
say okay it was very interesting game I
think something like new idea I played
in D5 it is very dangerous I mean it is
very risky for black
but I tried to play interesting chess I
see how Fabiano play in this tournament
it was not easy to play solid chess I
just
think it's better to play something
curiously win or lose like this I mean
but I think he was he played very good
in opening but
some mistakes and after a good good
position in Middle game and I will I
think chess fans all over the world are
very happy with your win today because
suddenly Norway chess is back on it's
it's a competition again yeah I think is
of course is a very important moment
because for we played fantastic chess in
first four games
uh today he also played not bad I mean
just I think something people under I'm
in the middle game of course I hope
tournaments will be interesting and uh
another players also will get some
chance for first place I'll say it like
it's meant to be said the first four
rounds karwana played Excellence
yesterday mum with the art of played
excellent chess congratulations thank
you very much thanks
and there we saw a beaming chakra
mamajarov who just defeated Fabiano in a
fantastic game and of course that
victory means that everything gets
shaken up somewhat because Fabiano is
still at the top of the table but one
point behind him chasing his tail is
Hikaru Nakamura well this round was
quite something and I love the way Mama
jarov played and he he was telling this
that well he wanted to play interesting
game he always plays interesting games
and he's shaken up the tournament by his
victory and indeed I also can agree that
Fabi did not make such huge mistakes but
little by little somehow he slipped
during the game and it was of course
very painful for him but Mama deserves
it I think yeah he just definitely
deserves it was a great game by all
accounts right David yeah fantastic game
and Ivanka you mentioned shaking up the
standings in Norwich it's also taken up
the world rankings Fabiano started today
at world number two he suddenly dropped
down to world number four and who's
replaced him it's Hikaru Nakamura in
world number two right now so uh yeah
the Chess World is watching this
tournament and everything's happening
right now I didn't realize that but I
well who knew and uh let's take a look
at how today's scores have impacted the
standings and still at the top is
Fabiana karona with ten and a half
points out of 15. Hikaru Nakamura are
chasing him by one point is with nine
and a half points out of 15 and Ali Reza
faruga also making some inroads with
seven and a half points out of 15. and
uh well Magnus also moving up from
eighth place down now to sixth place
with six points out of 15. as we enter
the last four rounds anything can happen
especially people start winning their
games in their classical section
absolutely and we see also there that
mamajarov is really gained a lot of
spots in the tournament so anything can
happen and of course let's look at
tomorrow's matchups
ariantari will have the white pieces
against Magnus Carlson I remember in
their last classical encounter it was a
draw and ariantari sensationally
defeated Magnus in the Armageddon will
we see history repeats itself we'll find
out and what other matchups are you
excited about
well I think I'm definitely which is a
most curious about its alireza versus
Hikaru that will be one of the top
matches I would like to follow
yeah and for me it's Fabiano can't he
bounce back can he maintain his lead
tomorrow black against Abdus it's not
going to be easy it's certainly not
going to be easy
and uh okay we've had an incredible day
what have you like been most excited
about well of course the most exciting
game was by far for me Fabiano versus uh
Mama jarov it was also very interesting
to see how Magnus was playing against
onage the classical game especially it
was engaging and it was also very
interesting to see how gokish converted
his Advantage into draw
to win the Armageddon it has been an
emotional day with you know bounce backs
we also saw Fabi suffer his first defeat
David what are your thoughts about today
my thoughts are simply that it set up a
perfect second half of the event I can't
wait for the last four rounds now just
because classical chess keeps rewarding
us and the Armageddon is a nice kind of
uh bonus on top it's the cherry on the
cake so yeah long may that continue in
the second half I agree David long may
the drama continue this is what we want
this is Norway chess the home of
Fighting Chess it's been an emotional
day and we are looking forward to seeing
you all tomorrow same time same place 5
PM Central European Time thank you
everyone for watching see you tomorrow
foreign
thank you